You wanna get more,
Huh?
No,
that's good.
You sure?
Yeah,
I'm good.
You positive?
Yeah,
I'm really caffeine.
All right,
go or we live.
Yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight and enter in the code name Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sex toy from men.
Shut Sam,
and we've all used it.
We all give it thumbs up.
Joey Diaz,
you never use it though.
Did you know just the hand.
Just the hand.
Little finger.
That's it.
We were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com makers of Alpha brain,
o n n I t.com and enter in the code named Rogan and you'll get 10% off that.
Now.
Alpha brain is a cognitive enhancer.
If you don't believe it,
that's okay.
Just don't get mad at me and if you think it's too expensive poolies by the
ingredients separately and and enjoy.
You know I shit was actually looking at that.
I was looking at all the ingredients,
seeing if I could rebuild it and stuff.
And there were so many levels of all the ingredients that I knew and I was
talking to them to Aubrey about it and he bought like the best kind of
ingredients put it.
It's like if you want to get one of the components in it,
you could get it pretty cheap.
So there is going to be a cheap version of it,
like a lot of these ingredients and stuff like that.
But he definitely uses it because he definitely used as a higher quality uses.
The best quality can get,
but you can do a cheaper,
so if you want to do it cheaper and avoid all this stuff,
just stop yelling at
30 bucks a bottle.
And that's what took a dollar a pill,
a discount.
What do I get?
No,
I can't do the math.
It's like three bucks off.
Which I'm like that.
So what they pressing the code?
They get that?
No.
Okay.
It's not a bad fucking deal too.
I believe in this shit.
It works.
If you're broke,
I get it,
man.
It's no big deal
and by the fucking pills at $30 a pop for a month,
it's,
it's pennies a week.
It's,
it's,
you know,
that's what you break it down to $10 a day.
I mean if you really think about it,
if you have disposable income,
it's all about what do you use it for and you know,
for me,
health and,
and my overall sense of wellness and my ability to communicate if that's the
most important shit to me.
I need vitamins and good diet or like primary,
that's like one of the most important things you can have.
That's the things that I spend money on it and good masturbation and good
masturbation for the flashlight is that you bring them in all black and white
and bring it back and get it all back around dances here.
I'm excited.
Let's let the fire get this bitch rolling.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that was the highlight of my month.
That was pretty sweet.
Yeah,
it was the highlight of my month.
She listened to that so much in the last 24 hours.
Then I'm thinking about making a ringtone,
but,
oh,
it's a good ringtone.
You know the perfect thing about it too,
so it wasn't perfect.
It didn't even make sense.
Yeah.
Cause they,
when he says also when he says or day
or something like that,
you have your phone next to the shit
you do.
So why you pointed Joey?
No checking around and I was checking around during the circle.
Yeah.
Well it's trained by day Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
Yet the night party almost as like die or day or something like that.
As far as confused as perfect.
Nick is awesome.
Holy Shit.
What a fucking fight that was.
God Damn Joe Diaz.
I was fucking fired up.
I want him to cry.
It gave me a cookie.
He had rite aid before the flight and by the time Chuck Congo fought me trio and
I was fucked up.
Like you know when you sit over in that section,
those lights hit you.
I don't know if they ever affect you by mistake.
They usually put like these orange,
red kind of lights,
blue lights and that cook.
He made those lights,
like I couldn't even see the fucking fight and I'm like,
get this beam of light out of my eyeballs.
And then by the time a Bj,
when Bj came up,
drove,
when he listened,
it was too close to it with fight for anybody to call.
My heart was doing involved with Bj.
I really liked that while the Bj.
Yeah.
So I didn't want to really call it and when I was watching Bj,
come on,
I just wanted a decent fight.
You know Jesus fucking Christ Jesus fucking Christ.
What a flight home
shit.
Nick Diaz look good man.
God Damn did he look good.
That's the best,
the best performance I think anyone has ever had against Bj.
No one has ever looked that good against Bj mean.
He just boxed him up,
standing up,
man.
Just boxed him up.
And then the pace that Nick's Nick Diaz makes you run with him.
He makes you run at his pace,
you know,
and his endurance is just on some wicked level man.
And he forces this pace and fights guys using sharp boxing where he doesn't hit
you with full blast shots.
You know,
like he sort of 50% to 50% to you up until like the second,
third round.
Then he starts digging all the hugs to the body and so effective man,
he's so effective.
It's a,
it's really weird to watch it.
It was,
it was a great fucking fight.
And I'm like I said,
I just,
I like going to,
you'll see the see fights,
you know,
I'm a fan,
but I also want to see a flood.
Once you some crazy,
she'll see some crazy shit.
And then they just announced the my other men,
Donald's Sarone against Nate Diaz.
Well we can fucking Donald still rolling.
And My,
I love him.
I've always loved him as a,
as a human being,
as a fighter.
But the other night he came out looking good like a motherfucker.
He was like super and 73 he was just,
he was just moved.
He just looked good out enough.
Thank you very much for taking.
Thank you for coming man.
You were the life of the party.
We um,
I talked to Greg Jackson,
yeah.
About,
and he said he's never been more disciplined.
That's what it is.
He's just constantly training constantly that Jim just working harder than he's
ever worked before.
He realizes,
I think that he's knocking on the door right now.
He's like right there.
I mean,
he's at the elite of the elite.
You know this knock out a Seaver.
The way he puts Seaver out,
dude.
Ooh,
that was big.
That was big.
Did he did that to see,
let me see if there's a dangerous guy,
man.
Look with CBRE did to Andrea winner of that,
that turning side taking landed on Nate Moore sent him flying across the room.
He's a beast man.
He's no joke.
And Donald Cerrone just ran through him and I've done that right after.
He did the same to Charles Olivera.
So Ron,
he's a monster man.
He's fun and he's a cowboy fucking character.
Legit cowboy man wears cowboy boots and shit's got to hap rides bulls.
He doesn't give a fuck around man.
So he lives on a ranch man.
You know,
like go saying like when they were calling him cowboy Cerrone when he was about
to step in the octagon.
I'm like,
well this isn't a joke.
This guy lives on a ranch.
Okay.
He's got his own ranch.
These,
these are real cowboy boots because he wears them and it's a real fucking cowboy
hat.
He's a beast now I seen something on Twitter earlier is of a given conduit
Ellenberger or somebody else in the meantime.
I don't know.
What if it was just a ranch style house?
You know what if it was in a real ranch and this whole time he just misheard it
and then you're like go to his house.
You're like,
oh he did spot some cowboy boots and he has a one story house.
The Vegas,
which really fucking missed.
I like came home and actually watched it was the Bull Riding Association finals
with the cowboys everywhere.
The other stand be the hats.
The Shit get,
cause I knew that.
I was telling Joe.
Yeah.
You know,
sometimes I'll misquote,
quote my words,
you know,
I don't hate fucking anybody.
I just hate people who like think that better than you are Snobby People Aka
Wash,
you know my heart is the south.
Let's get down to it.
When I fucking came to this country,
I was a little kid when I seen a cowboy hat and a gun.
How are you fucking kidding me?
You know what you feel like when you see that we all want to be cowboys.
That's where we fuck fucking dressed as our first Halloween.
Somewhere along the line and I,
all three of us,
we were a cowboy for a day.
You know what I'm saying?
That we all giggle.
You wouldn't have a played a fucking cop.
Why?
Bet You did with the girl next door.
You tied her up and dirty fucking bastard bug.
Brian wasn't even an Indian.
He was the boy that worked in the shop.
That's where he played.
Everybody else played cowboys and now I put Indian and I trustless usually
there's a lot of people that want to be rebels.
They played Indians.
I play Indian after I've seen Charles Bronson and uh,
the one movie when he played in a chat channels land,
he plays an Indian.
He threw the fucking speed.
I started throwing fucking sticks outside.
They'll stick ball.
Charles Bronson can pull off in the uneasy,
right?
Well,
in the 60s,
they just let you do whatever the fuck you want it to.
I mean,
Anthony Quinn's a Mexican,
they played,
how fucked up is that?
Anthony Quinn is really Mexican,
a great actor.
And he played everything well,
he played a Mexican in that one black and white movie.
But what was that movie that he played with Kevin Costner?
Do you remember that movie with Kevin Costner where Kevin Costner was in love
with his wife?
One of the greatest beatings ever?
Forget Anderson Silva kicking.
What's his name of the face?
The Guy fucks his wife,
who's the crazy chick who was no longer like a hot actress.
She was very hot at that time.
And when they shoot Anthony Quinn was a drug or Mexicans rug,
fucking savage who was fairly and stones Madeline Stowe.
No.
Viagara revenge was like 87.
There was no Viagra and he was just banging.
This chick wanted to keep getting banged and he came in and broke his legs,
slashed his face,
put her in the fucking brothel.
Shadow would fucking coke.
I mean,
Anthony Quinn didn't fuck around and revenge.
That was a scary movie,
man.
Probably.
Did you watch anything scary caught up in yesterday from the beginning,
but we got caught up in the motherfucking extra since yesterday.
And to watch,
you know what everybody talks about Friday the 13th I forgot.
Because all you think about is this movie about a kid getting possessed and is
so fucking deep.
The cinematography,
when he pulled them,
the priest comes.
Not the,
not Jackie,
you know Jackie Gleason and southern Lord lead me while you do this to me.
That's Jason,
Patrick's mother fucking father,
Rick Dude.
That never even been another movie.
He just did that,
that priest,
the boxer.
Really?
But yeah,
he's bad that it's kind of crazy.
Look,
I didn't do that many moves.
Bumps and beautiful that he was.
Yeah,
he was really fucking,
that's kind of crazy.
He was so good in that movie and he never did another movie because that movie,
one of the thing can you click on and then they wouldn't anything cause if it
didn't,
I'm going to blow up a fucking studio.
I'm going to blow up one of these fucking jerk offs.
You something.
That movie took me.
This girl was 12 years old.
There's one when she tells me your mother's sons Cox in the house,
you can't write that shit.
She takes the crush,
you sticking to her monkey and then she takes the mother,
puts her head down and says suck me.
In her contract.
They should've said,
listen,
I'm going to give you 50 grand a year for psychological abuse.
It was 1970 this kid was saying those words.
What do you think that did die?
But she was a free camp,
made us up with James Bitch.
She went right to buffalo one way.
It was something.
There's another scene in that she's shoving the crossing.
It's making noise like it's gotten into me like it is,
you know they shut fucking freezer so that they don't know that breathe like
that.
Her breath,
the breath was like,
wow,
what a fucking amazing,
amazing.
I was sitting there going,
I got to save this for the podcast because again,
back on the fucking seventies back to the fucking seventies and it didn't mind.
Fuck you like a hand coming out of a wall in mind.
Fuck you.
Slowly if they didn't have the special effects so they had to do it with writing
and they had to do with the way they shot things.
You know they're special effects mean she just had a little makeup on her face.
It's really not that blue today.
What do you remember that song?
Yeah,
she was the creepiest fuck when he gets out of the cab,
Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun Dun and often she opens that door.
It's just fall behind him.
That is one of the greatest fucking shots.
If that motherfucker was at my house,
I think I just slammed the door on.
This is bad ass.
How's it sound?
The beginning,
they find like a talisman or something like that,
which is why we believe,
that's why I've always thought there's so much fucking bad luck in Africa
because the devil that's a doubles house,
that's the devil's house,
Africa.
Egypt is that scene when he sees the devil statue and he looks and it's two dogs
fighting.
Oh Joe Rogan to wild dogs in the cycle.
I don't.
He is.
The guy comes out,
pops out with the shotgun like in an Arab suit,
isn't an Arab fucking country.
What?
He finds that thing.
But then when he goes to her house,
there's one part would be me while you do this to me and not my fucking mother.
Fuck.
Oh my God.
He has to leave the room and fucking cute.
That green soup and it's fucking high.
Just brilliant.
And when,
back then you have to think there was nothing like this before this movie.
Nothing.
But they had those old wolf man movies are
so stupid.
I mean,
they were fun,
but there were nothing like the exercise man.
He actually says to taking it to a deep,
deep psychological level.
That movie scared the fuck out of a lot of people out of people and then they
reduced it like they did it with her walking down the stairs and a fucking,
oh,
all the plot that he looks stupid.
She walked in their own Omoplata.
Yeah,
that was terrible.
And it they ruined it.
But that took away from what the whole movie was about.
Those are like the scenes they cut out,
which they cut them off for a fucking reason cause it's sucked the second when
people go,
oh my God,
they just rerelease princes unreleased saying he didn't release them because
they sucked.
You know what I'm saying?
He's,
this is first ranch.
You're dumped fun.
This hits and misses that.
Except that you don't know.
Yeah,
that movie was a fucking classic.
That's one of the movie.
They just did it so well.
It was so well done in every way.
There's a few movies like that.
We'd go back and you watch them and go,
God damn,
they just nailed this shit.
And everybody was a superb actor like there was.
They set you up for it.
Well,
a lot of people forget that there was a party,
there was a party at a house and there was a fight between a Jewish guy and a
German,
the German,
and he kept saying fucking Nazis.
Then they got into a misunderstanding.
So when she's first started getting sick,
she leaves the mother and when she comes back,
the director got found in the bottom of the steps,
was head twisted all the way around.
Yeah,
they set it,
they set you the fuck up.
The cop comes over,
he interviews them.
What happened,
you know,
and then like,
Yo,
now you're thinking maybe the girl killed the fucking guy.
Right.
But she went downstairs and Pete,
when they were playing the piano,
she goes to the restaurant,
you're going to die up there,
minister,
and then pisses in the ground.
Just,
just,
just shit that you can't even have a little girl with that Kinda face look.
No,
no,
you're getting it tonight.
You got to pull up.
When she comes out of the Yag and the priest comes up and he is,
he's a father,
goes to her.
Does she remember anything in the mother?
Goes,
no,
she doesn't remember gun damn thing.
She gets in the car,
she comes out and hugs and kisses him.
That's seen them fucking kill you.
It will fucking kill you.
It's such a great little fucking dirty scene.
Anyway,
I don't know.
And I said you guys remember that movie house from like 1986 house.
So I'm hormone.
It's a horror movie.
And they did from cheers or isn't it George wind or whatever and guys,
I don't remember that at all.
Nevermind.
I know.
I mean listen,
I nightmare on elm street and the first couple of those,
when I first watched them,
I'm not a hardware guy,
you know,
I'm not a big horror guy so I get scared.
I can't fucking sleep at night.
Like yesterday to watch that,
I watched Dexter and there was something else.
I can't fucking sleep at night with all that horror of my life.
It's all I want.
I don't want Dexter,
I don't want like serial killer type Har.
I don't want to like real live shit.
I like monsters.
That's what I like.
I like shit.
That's not real because that's fun for me.
When I go to a movie,
the last thing I want is you to recreate real life.
I get enough real life.
I don't want,
I want vampires.
What do you got?
Who can fly?
Who shoots?
Laser beams of the rivals?
Yeah.
If you don't have that,
I don't want to go see your fucking million.
I got movies and that got movies to take my mind the fuck away.
Aka Cop gun.
I got movies and that got Calgon take me away.
Yeah,
you can take,
there's movies that you watch.
I want,
I want to watch a movie that half the way there was a movie.
You're asking yourself,
where's my life headed?
Right.
And you're giggling.
That's all that matters.
Right?
Like sometimes I catch myself watching road house.
I ain't going to fucking live.
Oh,
that's a great television.
I'll watch it all the way through Ben.
Cause Ira,
let me flip a coin.
Oh Bonnie,
the coin.
There's just some get rich off a lot of people in this town and I'm going to get
richer.
Yeah,
just some worries.
Dialogue ever.
That movie's a class.
Some dumb movies.
I'm ashamed to tell people.
Able to like,
you know the scene where the stitching,
Charles Pat Patrick Swayze up,
she stitched him up and he goes pain don't hurt.
Pain don't hurt.
She would have like a video game for that.
Like a first person shooter or road house where you just like going around bars
and kicking ass.
Like going through clubs and crowds being a bouncer bouncer and craziest bar
ever.
Yeah.
They could have something like Bas levels,
the woman's restroom or something.
It was,
they weren't even bounces.
They were cooler.
Shit bounce.
I want you to be nice until it's time to not be nice.
Those are the cocaine days,
man.
They made different movies.
They made stupid movies cause they didn't know the movies were stupid because
they were all coked up or they're making them and they all had this idea that
they all had bad soundtracks.
They all like really like,
did you ever see man hunter?
Is that what it is?
The original silence of the lambs,
I believe it was called man.
What?
The Dude from Asi,
William,
what's his name?
I can't think of his name.
Whatever homeboy's name is.
That's a weird fucking movie.
Good fucking mood.
We'll take good.
Brilliant.
That's Michael Mann.
His early days,
he got William Peterson.
This is story about William Peterson was like,
he put them in thief,
he's got one line and fee.
If he takes a stick is going to hit James Gunn.
That's him.
That's really impede us,
but he put him in men.
Then I think we'll end penis and then he put them in one of the best movies to
live and die in La,
like a mother fucker.
People forget about that.
The line I have stolen,
I pull him to his face and he goes,
what?
Mine and I go,
that line is,
I stole from him like [inaudible] 83 when John Turturro's in the jail and what's
his name goes to visit him when he first gets busted at the airport,
would it kind of his money?
And he goes,
listen to sit tight.
I'll get you out.
And he looks at me.
He goes,
yeah,
and the check's in the mail and I promise not to cum in your mouth.
And then he goes,
listen,
you just,
it's all going to work out in a couple of days.
And they also,
can you hear the bell go off?
He's got to stop visitation.
He's drinking Kale,
Penn state,
which makes the,
uh,
the visit even strong.
He's got a fucking also,
and as he's leaving he knocks on the glass and he goes,
don't forget about me and that's it.
That's your line too.
I get that line.
Forget about me.
Don't forget about me.
He just walks away through the midnight and shit.
That's a great movie.
Eat each other member.
That's what that one was.
She was an artist type woman and shit like that.
And that was a good,
what's the name of that dude?
Dog.
But he played last temptation of Christ.
He's just start to live in Dianella which Gyns at William at the front of it.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Yeah man.
He was great.
He was great in that movie.
Fuck yeah.
You know what's crazy about the axis is like before ecstasy and before fucking
with all of these things,
it was a drug called THC crystal THC crystals.
This is 1976 to about 80 it was a designer drug.
It was,
there were supposedly THC.
There are the sticks and stems.
You boil them and whatever rises to the top,
you scrape it off and you freezing,
you snort it.
But what it became was something completely different like you would,
but for 10 bucks,
three people could get hot.
That's the first thing I ever snorted in my life.
I never did blow like that.
Then I just did this one thing.
People like snorted dry and one night I did that through the crystal between two
people and I went fucking home and that's one of the Times that was one of the
of sharing like lady and the tramp.
I don't know how we shared it.
We came in a little aluminum foil and you just,
you gave it to your buddy and he went and it tastes good.
It tastes like it tastes just like a vitamin fucking.
15 minutes later your vision would just cross,
but one night I went home and put that fucking excesses on and I nearly had a
heart attack.
Who was the effects of this stuff?
Like what was it like,
but your menu,
it was just this a fucking uh,
design.
The name for
Angel Dust.
That's all it was.
It was a designer in the 70s all that shit was big in New York.
They call it something else.
When you went to buy weed,
a little envelopes,
Brown envelopes that you folded up,
trays a fives and tens.
Lydia would always go out.
Then not only would they have a name for the week,
the master mix,
the super mix,
they go,
we also got whatever killed somebody that week.
Like when I first came,
the Len bias,
Len bias or of the Guy Anna,
like the first time I went over there,
it was the Guy Jones,
Jeff Jones,
Jones Gypsy.
That's what he put in the mother fucking Kuwait.
So you move,
is it,
and why that was always the case,
right?
Wasn't that always the case when somebody would die named some shit and tell you
this is the shit that put him on the moon.
This is her shipping.
Did you shit and putting me on the moon.
I was,
it was like 87 85 or 86 when Len bias died.
And I said,
shit,
they gave Kennedy before they put them in and I still remember going to Harlem
that week and like,
not even thinking about it,
like Lenny bias died,
left lefty drives out was the culture was the first time he had ever done blow
whatever.
And I'm in the car and I pull over and we'd go get weed and Harlem and all of a
sudden some black guy comes around the thing and he's like,
Yo,
I got the shit that killed Lenny bias.
I had to stop and like fucking almost dropped the one day.
I have never heard that before.
It was dark.
There were pit bulls out.
I didn't give a fuck.
I just dropped.
I had never heard.
That's your marketing.
Could you imagine someone died from Tylenol?
You know,
people don't.
People are doing it when they were,
when people were poisoning it.
That's what that was,
bro.
This is what they put the Tylenol challengers imagined.
Tylenol was saying that.
That's my point.
That the edge of the Tylenol was sound Yodas and shit to kill them.
20 people.
Can you hang,
can you hang dog and sell it?
We can't even sell it inside cvs.
We gotta beat in the parking lot.
This is the shit that we gave that dude when he got shot in the head and he
drove us up to the hospital or shit like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Fucking bullying and stuff like that.
Why is it always that?
It's always the shit that killed the latest guy.
Kadafi Kadafi his ass.
Did you watch it and then getting off your footage a little bit?
Little bit.
Holy Shit.
That's strange.
That's a,
could you imagine?
We have footage like that of Hitler Hitler's last day.
You know Kadafi went out hard,
dude.
He went out,
asshole dude.
He,
yeah,
he went out to animals.
They ripped him apart and shot him basically close.
People were screaming Allah Akbar and they were shoving sticks up his ass.
You can find photos online of them shoving us,
stick right up his ass.
They got a still frame.
It was real hard to see what the,
what exactly,
what,
what's going on in the video.
They still use the Motorola razor.
It look like the looking at something along those lines.
It was not a good camera.
It was a shitty camera and there was so much movement on the screen.
There's so much action that the camera would like made things almost like stop
motion.
It was like it was missing frames,
you know,
look terrible.
Very artsy.
There's some guy who they're going to do it.
You should see how they edited it.
No,
no,
no.
It's obvious.
But what a miserable way to die would have fucked it.
Sticking your ass.
You well they shot him.
Well the coalition forces,
we're going to come and get him and take him away and one of the guys shot him
now even after your shot,
I mean you breathe and you have a couple of minutes of whatever right there.
They're pulling your pants down and sticking a broom handle up your ass.
You guys a knife and it was a nine.
It was a knife.
I just read a thing the other day,
that website,
it was like a news website and they were saying that David went frame by frame.
You can see,
you can see where it's taking a little blood stain too.
Like he was spotting,
you know,
period Gadhafi period.
Brian.
No,
I'm not going to do that.
My cookies,
rebel shoves knife of Qaddafi's but for killing him.
Wow.
Yup.
Exactly.
But it's a,
what's crazy dude is the,
how,
how nutty it is like to watch this guys last moments,
there's only screaming and he's covered in blood and he's looking around
horrified and they're screaming La and they kept taking the and putting in
front of their face,
like they'd led look right at the camera and screen
hello walked,
Blah,
hello lockba up and then go back to chaos and blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Being God is great.
God is great.
What?
Yeah,
it's pretty fucking nuts man.
That's a,
that's a crazy part of the world.
Scary.
You know,
I dressed up as a wizard and scared a bunch of people at a party and it just as
the black wizard and uh,
I think it made people nervous cause I got,
I bought really realistic guns like fake guns.
I think Google black wizard would fucking skin we the pieces,
you understand me?
I'm watching the PR,
I'm looking at a photo of this guy's shoving a knife up his ass.
Yeah.
You see a little blood spot.
Yep.
He shoved a knife and cut off his ass.
Oh that guy will be talking about that forever.
That'll be like,
that'll look be his family's legacy.
You know the photo,
the photo of the guy who shoved the knife of Qaddafi's ass did is my father.
I was the guy.
Yeah.
I'm watching this picture that's deep.
He shoved a deepened his ass too.
It's a crazy way that guy died
but he's multiple stab him or just shoves and lights up the stairs.
Tell because in the video is really hard to tell
some good photos of his dead body,
though there's a bullet in his forehead and tune his chest and some a high
quality photos of his body putting nuts,
man,
it's this,
we've never had that before.
You know,
I never had a,
the video of a guy getting attacked by a mob and killed.
It's thinking it's 20 years.
It's going to be in three D and shit.
It's going to be like the best quality.
We're going to get high quality,
more video footage,
stuff like this.
It's going to get worse.
It's going to get to the point where we're to be able to experience what Gadhafi
felt with a knife being repaired.
How fucking far have we come like that?
I go so many more shit going to get the tape.
Now in my hometown in North Bergen,
they have command centers.
People watch videos and they have cameras controlling the city and they call
them hot spots.
You know like,
well I'm hot spots.
It booted me out.
He'll fucking taping you.
Yeah,
well creepy shit.
You've got to catch them.
That's where from con to that,
the from New York,
I understand,
but the fucking tape.
It's true.
You know,
I mean I thought there was something more of this and that they might not be the
only people.
I mean the,
you know,
I don't walk off and fucking Vegas.
You don't want to go off from there.
Not that I even take a shower with underwear on and those mother fuckers,
mother fuckers in Vegas,
we'll tape you photos.
You have to assume,
you have to assume that there was of Joey Diaz beaten off.
There's no dog.
Forget it.
I even used,
even when I a coke in Vegas,
I just,
that that little fucking bungalow bathroom with the lights out.
You know what I'm saying?
So nobody would fucking see me.
Fuck you.
And like flatten there.
The double check,
nobody would even pop their head out of the fire in the apartment just like
those motherfuckers fucking with me.
Jack,
you think that they video you while you're,
uh,
you have to assume in Vegas there's so much liability.
I agree.
So much liability.
They had to lose that,
watching everything.
So if someone goes in and kills a hooker,
they have video footage of it and they call him,
pop it up somewhere.
Hold on.
They have it on camera number seven,
which is like a camera behind a paying member.
I quarte no,
I could be a Buchi.
I'm sorry.
Not like Quarte r Courtney was a lighter weight fighter.
I may have Bucci the president,
he called himself the president.
He was a killer dude.
Uh,
a big fucking scary dude who was on the re on the way to being the heavyweight
champion.
It was a crusher dude is knocking everybody out,
but he liked to beat the fuck out of hookers,
like to get hookers and beat the fuck out of them and just do creepy shit to
him,
rape them and shit.
And so,
uh,
they,
they arrested him and he's in jail on that now the panel illegal done it a bunch
of times,
but he did it in Vegas.
Yeah,
yeah,
I did in Vegas.
Yeah.
But he was a crazy,
dangerous,
scary dude.
One of those big giant fucking 250 pound ultra athletes is beating the fuck out
of everybody.
Everybody's terrified.
I got bad Bucci when do,
when he gets out of jail,
you know I have to also assume the airport bathroom at the airport.
Yeah,
I say that too.
I have to assume that and a,
and I know when the plane would.
Yeah,
and I would want them to,
in a way,
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not going to shoot at the fucking lamp.
That's disgusting.
But I'm sure they have like technology.
If you're masturbating or something,
it must detect something,
a warmth that the chemicals must give off or a warmth that that's something I
don't,
I'm not really,
you know,
beat,
but if the chemicals and bombs and shit like that,
I'm just saying that you have to assume when you go to Vegas.
I heard a story years ago about a girl going to Vegas on her honeymoon.
Girl I grew up with,
went to Vegas on a honeymoon and five years later she went to the Poconos for an
anniversary and she rented a point or with a husband that was her fucking on her
honeymoon in Vegas.
And they sued the casino for three or $4 million.
This is in the eighties so if that was going on in the 80s and I have another
friend that I spoke to when we were in Houston,
Texas.
He,
before he became a cop,
he got busted snorting coke in the bathroom in Vegas.
And when he came out,
they arrested him.
This is fucking 1981 or two so they were filming the toilets and the bathroom
till this day.
He does shit.
They're filming you.
You have to assume that's incredible.
After fucking assume that our privacy now and at places like that at Las Vegas,
this gotta be ultra fucking security.
I would,
you know,
I'd have to just in all areas,
casinos,
they,
I heard,
oh,
you were with me when we were talking to Alex Jones and Houston.
He was saying that in two years they want to have fucking the pat down people at
the malls.
It Shit.
I parks and national parks,
you know the people like Psa,
is that what you call him?
Tsa?
Yes.
But you have to assume,
you know,
that is that they're watching you.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't do nothing wrong.
You want to arrest me for smoking dope scratching my nuts.
Go right ahead.
And I mean,
that's the worst thing I bought.
I know,
you know?
Right.
You know,
whatever.
It is a interesting questions like how much is your privacy worth?
Is it worth people being able to do creepy shit and get away with it?
You know what?
If one of your friends got killed and it was in a bathroom and they could have
arrested the guy,
but there was no video camera because people were scared of the video footage.
You know,
when you can say,
well,
Hey,
a guy got free because there was no evidence.
But meanwhile,
if they had a camera in there,
we would have caught them.
I gotta be in jail.
It's the streets.
The streets would be saver.
Now,
let me,
let me ask you this kind of somebody,
one of our friends did get killed in the bathroom and Vegas and poured a weapon.
We don't want to get nobody in trouble.
Did tape it.
[inaudible] would it be admissible?
That's the other fucking thing.
I could come to you as the head detective.
Go come in for a second.
This a situation.
We tape everybody.
You've always known that we've got the fucking guy.
We just need for you to go here answering,
but we got the guy
chambers.
The judge's chamber.
Yeah.
You're like,
all right.
You guys have to situation.
He killed him in the bathroom.
That isn't admissible.
That's the fucking problem.
You don't have here,
so you have to,
you'd have to find out what the laws are.
How did you,
okay,
I come into your house,
I think bathroom.
I'm not going to get door.
Mrs Rogan opens the door.
I smelled marijuana.
That gives me the right to come right in.
You smell that.
Let's go.
We all know why?
Because of homeland security.
Homeland Security.
They changed that.
You know how many fucking arrests have been for a actual terrorism through
homeland security?
It's been like 12 or 14.
And the arrests for drugs have been thousands.
Thousands.
So it's,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
It's,
it's uh,
I think the,
the actual t statistic,
it's probably like 1500 to 12 or something like that.
So I come in here and I'm looking for,
uh,
something.
I Dunno,
I see that I come in for the week and when I come in here,
I see a tee shirt that you wore that you ripped off when I was chasing and you
stabbed the guy.
Is it admissible DNA on it?
If I came in there without a warrant though,
I did have a warrant to come into your fucking house.
It's you and the cop against your wife's words.
I was,
you following me?
It's a very thin fucking line.
You know,
you can't go looking for something and find something else.
if I say that I'm going to go to the house,
a 100 liberty street,
it's a brown house.
And when I get there,
it's a blue house.
Cause what?
My warrant is fucking null and void.
Really?
Yeah.
The color of the house.
It's fucking crazy dog.
It's crazy how to the teeth.
So even if you broke,
if you went into that house,
if the warrant was Nolan void,
if you went into the house with the wrong color,
but you found dead bodies and guns and the warrant is no fucking good.
You walk my friend.
Whoa.
A little technicality on a warrant and wording.
You walk,
you fucking walk in this country.
That's,
that's how they start out.
Charles Bronson.
Moby's that's why we're fucking right.
Wasn't that that movie we're walking Deathwish didn't,
didn't,
wasn't one there wasn't it?
No,
that was,
it was,
but there was one movie where someone walked and Charles Bronson went after him.
The guy walked on a technicality or was it cleaning,
sweat,
whatever it was.
Michael Douglas and 81 the movies was called Star Chamber where he played the
judge in La fucking brilliant movie.
And two guys driving down the fucking street when they,
and a cop pulls him off of busted headlight and the cop goes,
I smelled marijuana.
They look into man,
they find a kid.
Shoot.
So they arrested him,
they bring the fucking guy in,
Michael Douglas,
the judge,
Blah Blah,
blah,
boom.
Because it was an admissible because they pulled him over for a broken
headlight.
They didn't really have the right to look at the thing and the court,
the kid's father shoots the fucking the cop.
It's a great story.
It's about a team of judges who have a hitman and whenever you beat them in
court,
they come looking for you.
So six judges sit there and go,
there's the crazy road.
Brian Brian Red band,
he killed this lady,
took the jewelry to a house,
and when they specify the color of his house,
Brown color of his house was white.
He got away with,
we'll try to get them,
what do you think it's going to kill him?
Guilty,
guilty,
guilty.
And the guy would go and fucking shoot you.
And then when they went after the kids,
who?
The cop that the people killed,
that kid,
they found out that it was the father.
So what was it called?
Star Chamber.
Our chamber.
Michael Douglas went after the guy to tell him that he received,
he won.
So he just saying anyone there was,
it was on,
you know how I know and I didn't feel like it was the first time I had HBO was
the classic Fucking Month I got.
It was raging bull star Chamber and Hollywood nights.
Is it good?
Which one starts saying hold up.
It's a nightmare.
I haven't,
it was silent.
He TWR about two months ago and I watched it for a little while and it's one of
those chances,
you know one of those channels on cable,
you know showtime.
They always have extra showtime.
Actually,
I don't fucking know.
But there was on one of those ones.
It is amazing when you go looking at and how many different channels there are.
We got 500 fucking champ.
Why did they put all the fucking HD channels way at the top and then put it like
on the middle.
Oh,
but use those music channels.
Someone's house and they're playing music through the TV.
Only ex girlfriends use those.
I mean it's like,
I liked listening to hades.
This go explosion.
Ain't bad dog to get your party psychotics,
disco explosion.
They have all different color names on it.
Every different though.
Brightwell Brooke,
Whatever.
I know there's a way to get XM radio.
How do you get XM radio in your house?
Because it has to go.
You call.
I think it's a subscription.
What is it?
They have the satellite in your roof or something like that.
Broadcast through like a channel,
I think music channel.
Are you talking about through your cable company?
I'm talking about XM radio.
Oh,
you just got to get satellite radio in your house though.
How's it picking it up?
Oh,
you get this little a tuner that comes with it or a lot of the devices now have
the Tinder built into the device,
but picking up from a satellite,
like if you go into a tunnel,
it won't work.
Is that what it is?
Right,
but it work in your house then.
It's just how it's built.
You just point it towards the direction of the house and whatever technology
goes through the walls.
It's not the best,
but I've done it for a long time.
It's a whole satellite thing is kind of weird,
right?
They have to throw it into orbit.
It seems kind of archaic now.
W The internet is so powerful fast.
It's like why would you throw it all the way up in the space and then bring it
back down?
You know what I mean?
Like why can't you just broadcast it through the Internet?
What do you know?
Cause they're trying to,
the Internet,
the bandwidth of the Internet,
but the backbone is getting,
even,
it's getting like a lot of loaded lately,
you know,
so much video transfers and stuff like that.
Satellite radio is not ones and Zeros they're sending,
they're sending something on radio frequency.
So it's not like bandwidth intensive.
It doesn't matter how many people are downloading it.
Right,
right,
right.
It's like it's off the network.
It's in space or something.
I might even be wrong.
I don't know.
You might be wrong.
Right?
You don't get to too many listeners on satellite radio and then it doesn't work.
Right.
It's not like,
you know,
you catch a website.
I don't think so.
Yeah,
so it's different.
That's funny.
It's like TV broadcast.
You know?
It's funny that bandwidth is like a big thing.
You know that it's like,
you know when you see a file,
you go,
wow,
one gig it's going to take,
you know how many people are doing that at the same time,
there's no union people downloading the same one gig update to Mac Osx and
you've got to look at that and go,
God damn,
how much bandwidth is that?
You know what's weird is that,
I think it was spring just released a report the other day that they just got
the new iPhone on their network and how the droid in Motorola,
they spend 30% or 40% more bandwidth than the iPhone.
They've noticed really because of the four G.
Is that what it is?
I know it's just more people just online.
I think the applications,
how they're designed,
there's more things streaming,
constantly connected,
I'm guessing.
Oh,
that makes sense.
It streaming because you know you were able able to get all those different
flash videos,
right?
You can't get on iPhone,
things like that.
Those four g phones are fucking fast,
man.
Verizon's four g I went to the store and I fucked around with that droid.
Bionic.
That thing is a slick.
If you have it in your area,
it's not,
I mean it's not everywhere.
You know,
like you probably won't get it here at this house.
Uh,
no,
I barely got it.
Got It.
Cause I have a four g card and I can get online with it,
but barely.
I noticed what the,
the a four s that it's twice,
it's two times faster than they had before,
but it's two times fast through 18 and t at and t sucks dude.
It's always fucking up.
When you're in any place where it's high volume,
you can't get a call.
You can't make a call or have any problems anymore.
The network's diluted.
I think you make as many calls as I do.
When I'm in my car and I'm driving in Jujitsu,
I'm driving to a comedy show.
I'm constantly doing business in my car to a businessman.
I'm a businessman.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm just getting,
my bend has done.
I um,
you know,
I always have to take care of shit.
I have to deal with successfully drive from my house to your house.
Uh,
hallway.
Really.
Is this a new thing?
Did you always were in the last three months?
Four months got better.
It's gotten a lot better really.
And My,
my data network at my house is like six megabyte download on the new iPhone,
so that's pretty crazy.
That's pretty crazy.
Well,
when I had it,
I couldn't drive to Hollywood and keep a conversation.
There was three places where it would cut out and it would drive me fucking
nuts.
I'd be like,
this is Hollywood in 2011 you know we had Anthony Bordain on,
he was talking about you can be in China in the middle of the fucking woods and
you got four bars on your phone like they got at wired over there.
They're,
they're like so advanced as far as like cell phone coverage and things like
that.
Yeah.
That,
that drives me nuts.
The at and t thing would drive me nuts.
And then when you're at the UFC,
I know this is still a fact when there's that many people in the arena,
when you're looking at an 18,000 seat arena and everyone jumps online,
you can't get online,
you can't get online.
It doesn't work.
It just doesn't work.
It shows you you got three bars and it won't get online and won't open anything.
You can't get on Twitter.
But then I get to Verizon,
boop,
right on.
Nope.
Yup.
It show you just got a new phone.
You got to enjoy fun.
Right.
You've got the,
yeah,
the spring EDV four g phone.
Uh,
what's your review on it and like why would your editorial,
listen man,
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I went online and tried to look up the directions on youtube to learn how to do
a couple things on it,
but I'm very happy.
Number one,
I was getting calls inside the UFC.
I've always been,
you know,
I don't know what a bad phone services cause I've always had spread as far as
the phone was concerned.
I like to,
I get emails when I do push it back button and ended up on Twitter.
I'm on it,
right.
I mean I'm a fucking Twitter.
I can't believe it.
It's something,
my thing and I can't see this thing is fucking huge.
You know,
if if you really need like,
and when I get texts,
I get two texts.
I get a text regular size,
it's going to hit it again and then I get this fucking term paper,
you know?
So it's pretty cool for me.
It works for me.
It's the camera.
I don't know how to use it.
So I'm about to come over.
That's why I called you last week.
Come over your house.
I was by Your House,
Huh?
How can it be hard?
It's just the camera on the phone.
If I pressed the wrong button,
I'm,
I'm fucking how Bailey at buying fucking dresses.
I don't know what I'm doing on the website.
And I started hitting,
so I've been learning things.
I downloaded apps,
now I read my apps,
you know,
I know how to do those things.
It's cool.
I say one thing for a,
for getting online.
You can't beat that big screen.
A battery life.
What do you think about that?
It's how I,
again,
you cannot,
I know what abusers,
if I get a youtube video,
look at a youtube video.
When I'm in the restaurant,
I was going to kill any fucking battery.
10 spirits.
What do you rate it?
10 spirits for?
For Joey Diaz.
For anybody else?
I'm very content with the service.
I don't know.
I'm going to have to get my wife's a iPhone and try her out and see where it
gets stuck and shit like that.
That's the sprint EVD for g something,
but no,
this is,
I got the shitty one.
I got the galaxy s Alex.
Yes,
but it's still the forecast.
a great phone,
Bro.
I can't even tell you the numbers.
I get this foot,
$80 a month with the whole fucking plan.
Just a few months ago it was the best Troy phone.
Are you fucking crazy guys still call me.
I'm,
you know,
a galaxy s two is supposed to be the shit that galaxy s two,
I suppose this one now there's another one,
right?
Yeah,
that's what I've heard.
Am I allowed to a text to yet?
Because
your family
bothering me.
Fucking just call me.
I've got some,
you know the funny thing is I Guess Tomorrow Redman fill me in.
I know.
What do you guys know what happens tomorrow with direct TV?
They loose Fox and everything.
Usually.
Uh,
I read the UFC wasn't in jeopardy then.
They didn't have to worry about it.
Don't know why you're fucking around with this direct TV's.
It's got a universe.
Yeah.
I think I'm going to,
I think it's great man.
Now what's the other?
Isn't the other one better than universe that I could go viral horizon?
No bias files.
No.
There's another warning cable.
The cable.
That's what I know.
No,
no.
Shoot yourself in the mouth.
Let it slowly.
Kelly.
This is a problem.
It,
it goes off.
Sometimes it goes off.
I have to reboot it and we lose the podcast sometimes.
I mean I have the highest level of cable they sell and you know,
a lot of times when we're uploading they'll say low bandwidth and I'll just kick
us off line and then we have to reboot.
We have to reboot it by Warner brothers,
you know,
and everyone would look at movies you're not supposed to.
It's not that good.
It's not the best.
Maybe it's my connection.
Maybe I don't have a good connection up here cause I'm kinda in the middle of
nowhere.
I don't know what it is,
but they told me I would get,
you know,
x amount of downloads speeds.
It's just not that good because I seen the shows that they lose if you have,
like the other day,
email emailed me like the shows I lose one of these shows is sons of anarchy.
Chuck's eat almost be jumping up and down,
get him saying you lose it if a,
if this goes
the fight.
Well Chuck Tito isn't,
he's suing sons of anarchy I guess.
I don't know.
What it says is that was like his idea.
I told her,
I came up to him,
I got a bike,
I got a fucking camera.
Come on.
Yeah,
I never watched that show.
Do you watch that show?
I started watching it this year because a buddy of mine's on the show and I
bumped into him after a few years.
I liked that guy,
Ron Perlman's,
those names everybody.
My friend was on it.
She says he was fucking great now.
He was just a really good guy that heard.
I bet he is.
He's hilarious.
Like guy's good.
He's getting a lot of movies.
He was good and drive [inaudible] drive drive yet.
No,
very violent but good movies guys.
I've done 30 years.
I still like a good car.
Chase a weld done car chase,
you know,
drive at some wild car chases.
If you watched the preview,
apparently it looks like that.
It was like a car chase movie,
like real action movie.
And some woman went to see it and sued because she felt like the uh,
the,
the previews misrepresented the film.
She didn't know it was going to be this weird,
moody sort of a dude with add or whatever.
The hell he's got.
You know,
it looks like he's,
he's got like a mild autism or Asperger's or something like that and he's out
there killing people.
Stoically cars two comes out on video.
You'll like that.
Then cars too.
What does that new Pixar movie that came out of that?
I would like the worst.
This lady suit.
She sued because she thought that the movie was not what she went to say.
Like,
oh,
how hilarious is that?
What a dumb bitch.
Does she really have money?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I don't think they've settled because they pay the fucking dumb bitch.
I don't think they've settled.
I think it's just one of those things you hear about in the news and you get
sued for anything now.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
Like fucking with anything.
Well,
are you got sued by like crazy skitzo guy for being a bad lawyer is Ari wasn't,
you know our who's pretended he was a lawyer to a crazy person.
You know,
looking back at it,
that was a really bad idea to saying that you're a lawyer and you know,
that's probably against the law.
I'm sure there's a law somewhere.
Like he can't tell people you're a lawyer.
There is always a comic.
These guy comes to a comedy club,
talks to Ari at Acom and club after Ari gets off stage or he tells him he's a
lawyer and he'll represent him as he's suing.
I mean,
come on man.
The real problem was the guy was crazy.
Yeah.
Just to the bone crazy.
That place,
that comedy store is a fucking magnet.
There's,
there's a vortex there.
I'm not,
I don't believe in hippy shit like crystals and this is the sacred part of the
universe.
This one area,
let's huddle and together like where I lived in boulder,
there was a,
a circle of rocks and this lady was like,
this Yoga Lady was into this rock circle and she was telling me that,
you know,
you have to stand in true north and accept the universe and this is a sacred,
this is sacred land.
I don't believe in that.
But I do believe there's something about the comedy store.
There is something about that place where there's crazy people walking down
sunset and they,
they,
they stop at that place and they just,
they just start walking,
start walking in that place we met more crazy place,
more crazy people at that place in any other place in Hollywood.
Like if you have a compare between the nuts that go to the improv and then not
to go to the comedy store,
there's no comparison.
Right?
It's two different fucking worlds.
Two different worlds,
two different worlds.
I know I will be a regular at the store and how people would say,
how do you go up there?
People are scared of that.
People are fucking scared of them.
Super dark playground versus treehouse playground versus treehouse commies.
There's like a playground.
Like any shit will happen,
you know,
it's out in the open tree house.
Like you're kind of like with the same people,
but you're kind of protected and it's more like,
you know,
chill for comics.
Nick Diaz would hang up in the Improv is a GSP.
Yeah.
GSP.
He's just a gentleman.
He's calm,
calmly store.
Look at the fucking we got and they were talking about Freddie Prinze.
Freddie prince goes back to the comedy store,
and that was the 70s you know,
21 shooting the fucking gun when they were coked up the fucking hill with that
crazy guy.
And you know,
this was a,
a home of dysfunction.
The owner was fucking the comics,
you know,
sucking their dicks Twitter time.
You know,
they had a house where they did blow and Louisiana,
Dyson,
Roseanne all lived through this fucking same house at one time.
Listen to the talent and that fucking room.
I mean,
you know,
when you have that intensity of talent,
you're going,
it has to go the opposite way.
You got to have that intensity because you're right on,
you're teetering right on that fucking fine line of brilliance and fucking
craziness.
It's somewhere in there.
It's the fucking commonly is that humor and that all that energy got sucked into
the walls.
It's something that,
that building has a feel to it.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
there's a guy named Rupert Sheldrake.
He's an evolutionary biologist who believes that everything has a memory,
that everything has some sort of,
uh,
like,
some,
some capability of a recording the past and that even furniture.
It's why people love antiques.
You know,
there's something not just about the fact that this character to it,
but it really gives off a feeling to it because it has so many memories in it.
If people using it,
you know,
that has a rich,
ancient feeling to it.
And people believe that that's the case with buildings.
You know,
that building's almost have a built in memory.
that they have something where,
you know,
if you like,
here's a perfect example.
When I was in boulder,
the Jonbenet Ramsey house was for sale,
or Jon Benet Ramsey.
Dot.
And it's a big,
beautiful house.
But it was cheap.
It was way cheaper than it would have ordinarily been.
And,
uh,
I remember,
talking about it with some friends and then what?
Fuck that I wouldn't fucking live there,
you know?
And why wouldn't you live there?
It's not like the,
the kid's going to come back to life.
It's not like the guy's gonna fuck you in the ass and knock you over the head
with a rock and kill you.
No,
it's,
it's already over.
The crime's been committed.
Now it's just a house.
Like why?
Why would you avoid that house?
Because that house has got a memory in it,
man.
There's a man we know inherently.
We know.
You know you would never do that.
You'd never be able to live there.
No.
It's like,
look,
I have gone in the water in places where people drowned,
you know?
Do you know what the Indians underneath this house somewhere,
that's my point.
I have walked on ground where I'm sure someone has died,
but a building,
a building where someone died,
you'd have to,
you got to plow that motherfucker over and start from scratch.
You've got to get rid of that building.
I'm very,
very fucking happy you had this conversation.
I am fucking,
cause I had something in my heart the last three weeks that has blown me the
fuck away.
And I know I'm not retarded.
I don't know.
Fucking crazy.
I went to New York to shoot the documentary about my life.
Right when my mother bought that house to deal was he went back to the house.
You grew up?
My mom had uncle,
so we had an option we could live in Fort Lee.
I don't know if,
forget that house was from George Washington.
Can fucking bridge or delete.
We had to fucking leopards in front of the house.
White statues.
I'm like,
Ma,
this is the house was,
we couldn't explain where the cash is coming from.
If we took the house in North Bergen,
the guy would work out some deal with the bank and we had no about the down
payment problem with the house in North Bergen.
They didn't tell us when we got the house,
after we moved in,
somebody had hung himself well downstairs and the block is on offer.
They just a dead end.
The fucking street,
which is bad luck.
Right fucking that dead in the streets.
That's just bad.
As the end of that board was an orff sprints,
a fucking orphanage?
No,
I lived in that house.
I seen,
uh,
I find my mom on the floor of that house.
I mean,
I grew up in the house.
Had on your mom died when you were on [inaudible] acid.
1415.
It's tested and it's just so weird now.
I had great times in that house as a kid.
I can't lie.
The low last people came.
I got my sucked.
I seen my first point.
Oh,
in the attic.
I smoked dope.
I remember after my mom died,
my dad came over to me on the street and he goes,
committed to cough for a second.
You had a box like this and he lifted the box up and he goes,
look in this box and it was three inches of roaches,
not cockroaches.
We'd roaches and he looked me straight in the eye because you got to stop this
today.
This is bad.
We would go upstairs and those days
we would go upstairs and we were 13 five of us and we buy half ounce of weed and
that when those days we wasn't that strong.
So you bought a half hour,
$25 we wrote 30 joints.
That's a good deal because you could still sell 25 joints.
Get your money back inside and smoke five.
We'd smoke them all five guys.
We'd sit there with an eight pack of Budweiser cans and we wouldn't go home to
every joint.
That bag was pumped and gone.
If the only way he'd go home with there was five of us and we said we'd take a
joint for the morning.
So you've been getting high steady since you were how old?
Steady steady's Freddy Steady Freddy that he 16 since you were 16 but when I was
18 and 30 plus years dirty,
I used to be an athlete and with wage run to the George Washington bridge,
but on Fridays I had my little freak crew.
I used to do karate with Mario Diaz.
Week we do homework and people don't know.
This is a picture of you right behind you,
over to your right shoulder.
That's when you were like a fucking fit athlete.
Look at you.
You animal fucking,
what are you talking about?
You're guide them football player there.
You were huge.
Don't fucking football player.
That's how you were when I first met you.
So people don't know.
It was just really weird,
Joe,
that I would,
I would lift weights and eat carrots and,
and then on the weekends I had my little fucking Guinea crew and they,
we get,
you know,
a case of Budweiser that we rub off a beer truck and we wouldn't tell,
nobody would had magazine and Cologne,
you know,
like nobody knew that we got high,
but we were jocks and then my mother died and they're not even really like
drinking.
So I had to do something when I went out with these kids.
So I smoked up.
I love drinking.
You know what?
I don't love the day after drinking fucker.
I love getting a little lit though.
It's fun,
Dude.
We went to a,
Joey and I after the fights we went,
oh,
you didn't come up to the,
you went to club mixer mix and we went up with my boy Justin from the action
report,
the guy who does the pool gambling videos and the holy shit.
We got hammered.
Woo.
We kept coming.
We just kept those drinks.
Comment.
Where's that one of those?
Wake up.
Go to the airport.
Three sleep for three hours.
Go to the outdoor.
No,
it was good.
Joe.
He got me a coffee though.
I kept me up,
but I was telling you that we went to my mother's house,
that same house and I,
whenever I go to North Bergen,
I was go to the cemetery and put flowers and I take a ride by the house,
but I never get out of the fucking car.
That's a complete different story.
Taking a ride and getting out of the car.
This time I actually got out of the car and went in front of the fucking garage
and talked.
It was like somebody was kicking my knees out like that was just like,
it was like I was getting wheezy,
like I was feeling bad.
I was feeling all those emotions because I never carry my keys on.
I'd always hide them in the back under the condition to pull out and open the
garage and the garage.
I was one of those kids.
And then the Cuban guy came up and we started talking and I told him that my mom
died in the house and he goes to people live there.
I'm watching the house there away.
You want to go on the back of the house?
And I went to the back when I played,
I was a basketball and it was over anxiety.
It wasn't even an anxiety,
but I could feel the walls,
I could feel the brick walls.
Like they knew,
you know,
like I had been there before and she goes,
if you want,
I could open up the place.
And that was too real for me.
I was like,
fuck that.
None.
I'm good.
Well,
even just the emotions of being around it,
even if there was no memory in the building,
just to the retreat occurring of your past,
you know,
old places like you ever been around your old high school,
please.
I wanted that when I went back all the songs,
grammar school,
and then did everything when I was a kid.
Um,
I used to have a problem when I was like,
it was when I was just starting to do stand up and I was like just starting to
move forward with my life.
I would go back to like where my high school was,
go back to Newton and I drove around and I would feel like I felt when I was
going to school there,
it would make me insecure.
I would feel like I felt like when I was in high school and didn't know what my
future was going to hold and was just really confused and I felt like a loser
and I would go back to high school.
It didn't matter how well I had done since high school.
How many taekwondo tournament side won or how many,
you know,
standup comedy shows I had done,
I still felt like a loser when I was around my high school.
It made me feel like it's still like I was illegitimate.
I wasn't confident enough yet.
You know,
there's definitely memory to it.
And like,
there's definitely like,
like if you got raped in the basement,
every time you go into the basement,
you'd probably be like basements.
Yes,
Brian.
But it's the main thing that,
this is how I justified it,
failing on the plane the next day.
Cause I even felt that the next day on the plate I felt really bad.
And I said,
you know what,
even if you had a childhood that was the president's son when you moved out of
the White House,
if you go back through the White House,
you still gonna get some chills.
Your souls are in those walls.
You talked to those wall.
He went to bed quiet one night.
You cried.
Oh,
I went back to the house where I grew up for the first time at 20 years.
Last week,
not last week,
last month I was in Boston.
And uh,
I went back and,
uh,
I stood in front of the house.
It was a real bizarre,
I lived in a weird section of a Newton upper falls.
I lived,
um,
it was pretty rural for where I lived.
I lived right in front of the Charles River.
There was like a big park in front of my house in the Charles River.
And then essentially there was a lot of woods behind there.
There's a lot,
lot of woods in that area.
But uh,
that's where I used to hang out when I was a kid and I went back there and was
walking around.
There's a spot called echo bridge in my house was the house right on echo
bridges,
38 Ellis Street.
And uh,
I went back there.
It was so fucking strange.
Everything about it.
Like you could just,
you just read all these flashbacks start popping into my head of,
you know,
of walking nothing in these,
on these same streets and standing in front of the same house.
The house looks exactly the same.
My father built that house,
so it was,
it was all real weird.
It was a stood in the exact parking spot or I caught my friend Adam
fingering this girl that I was dating.
I was dating this girl I dated,
I dated a lot of sluts and you know,
look,
no offense to them.
I'm sure there were good girls and I'm sure it's probably they're probably
fucked up,
which is why they were attracted to me in the first place because I was fucked
up.
But uh,
I did a lot of girls that cheated on me.
Holy Shit.
They were just horse.
I did this one girl,
she literally,
everybody that tried to fucker fucked her,
she could not pass,
she could not pass.
It was just,
she was just one of those crazy Catholic girls that was like suppressed her
whole life.
And all you had to do was try and you are banging her and everybody I know
banker and then when I was,
I was just sort of starting to dater and uh,
I got up early because I had a newspaper route and she was parked in front of my
house.
It's so crazy.
Fucking people are,
and they're both in front of my house and he's fingering her right in the right
on the front seat.
And I slammed my hand down on the hood and I'm like,
good morning,
I go,
you fucking crazy assholes.
And then I just got my car and I drove off and then,
but you know,
I fucked her a bunch of times after that,
but it never took her seriously again.
And it was one of those like,
okay,
now I see.
But that happened.
That was like an overwhelming pattern over and over again where a chick would do
something fucked up.
And then I never take you seriously again.
You know,
a couple of times it was girls who went on spring break one time a girl went on
spring bag,
girl I was living with this girl and she came back,
she was acting real weird.
I'm like,
what the fuck is up with you?
Like why are you acting so weird?
And then she had confessed that she,
she kissed some guy,
she said,
you tell me kiss some guy and you're on spring break and you fuck some dude,
period.
You come back all weird and say you kiss some guy,
you fuck some dude.
And you know,
we had a talk about it,
but we wanted up staying together,
but I never took it seriously again.
You know,
and it never bothered me again.
Like so like if I had the opportunity to cheat a bit,
like
I would,
I wouldn't even,
there was no,
it was like I was single.
It was like I had a girlfriend,
but I was single,
you know,
like the opportunity to,
she came up.
Yeah,
of course I would.
This pitch came back from spring break and she was fucking some other dude and
one girl with the spring break.
This is my best one.
She came back with fucking rug burn on her back.
Her whole back was like her whole lower back,
you know,
was just fucked up.
This dude just lit her up.
She went to Florida with her cousins or some shit and she came back and when I
asked her about it,
she told me that she was leaning up against the fence.
She was drinking and she was leaning up against a fence and there was like a
nail in the fence,
which is so ridiculous.
It's such a bad lie and again,
I couldn't prove anything so I stayed with her,
but I never took it seriously again.
I was always like a,
eventually this is going to end,
this cannot go anywhere.
This was the,
this is never going to be my wife.
This is never going to be the mother of my children.
This is just some crazy bitch.
That all right.
That's what happened.
Oh you had a nail and you scratch it up and down your back and big six inch
swaths.
Like whoever that guy was,
he fucked the shit out of her.
Go.
I like to talk to him about that.
He chicks in Jersey when I was growing up,
but beat that dirty
or I used to day from Michigan,
the one that threw me out when I first met you took my clothes and leather
jacket.
That's the crazy bitch.
I was fucking in the ass and Seattle when I felt something hit and my deck.
So I looked at her asshole like stuck like two fingers,
like something was hitting the top of my unit.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this sharp thing?
It.
And so I took my dick and I just put two fingers in.
They searched around her asshole and it felt like a fucking little like a a,
you know what you need to hurt?
She's balling aluminum foil that's inside the Hershey like half of it.
And I took it out but it was all wrinkled up and it was like this was pointing
over here and I just took it out,
look at it.
It was like kind of brownish and put on the table or something.
My dig back in there and finished up.
What?
Oh,
I came,
I just got up with toilet paper and picking up.
I never said man,
it was,
how do you tell somebody to have an aluminum foil?
And
I can say you have STD or something,
but aluminum foil that get that about.
Well why would you ask?
You know,
it was just a little piece where machine,
a piece of chewing gum.
She was a crazy fucking strip it,
check the logs.
You will remember that I was the one when I first met you.
Well,
that was some of the craziest shit I had been with crazy women.
I've been about people.
That's the first time I ever found out about sugar daddies.
Like she's the one that filled me and she's like,
well okay,
let me tell you this story.
I have this guy that pays my bills and I'm like,
bitch,
I'm getting a piece of that.
Fuck y'all getting the color.
That shit.
If he's paying and he's fucking you and I'm,
I'm again a peaceful.
You were her boyfriend towards the end.
She was my sugar daddy was the end like towards the end,
like in Seattle,
cause after Seattle was the same thing.
Like you,
you don't take him serious.
I didn't take it serious no more.
So you were just getting a piece.
Yeah,
it was getting a piece,
you know.
So you would tell her,
all right,
you could fuck this guy,
but I got to get some money.
I wouldn't say nothing.
Yeah.
I would say I'm taking a piece of,
and she goes,
you're fucking crazy.
I'm getting a fucking piece of that.
I mean this bitch,
listen.
She would say you're fucking him.
And I had,
I had fucked people before I had fucking come on people,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
But this was a different level.
Like she,
this was just a different level of retardation.
She would take pictures of my deck and shit.
I mean,
she was fucking nuts.
This chair,
like I don't know if she would bring strippers or was she brought up this one
girl over.
I just remembered this.
She brought this one girl over one day that was playing that I have a boyfriend
routine.
So this girl putting together,
eat her pussy and for me to fuck her from behind while she was eating her pussy.
But the girl wouldn't let me see your pussy because he had a boyfriend.
I'm like,
only a stripper would do that.
She's like,
she could see my titties.
Cause if he comes to the club,
you can see where it says,
but I have a boyfriend.
I don't want them to really see my pussy.
So my girlfriend's eating her fucking monkey and I'm pumping my girlfriend from
behind.
I'm trying to catch a piece of this fucking monkey.
She was a hot little job girl.
That was pretty fucking,
I couldn't catch a fucking monkey.
Like that's what people know.
That's the people she brought over like crazy shit,
like they was just crazy.
Then I got to duck the shooting that he came to Michigan.
He hand dirty crazy.
The Michigan the fist fight me.
So at the time I got,
that's the deal.
I didn't beat her up.
I was beating him up.
She jumped in.
I pushed her out the next day.
I'm not,
I'm beating up this fucking broad.
But once you had that shit on you,
you can't get rid of that.
Right.
Everything you do involves that domestic domestic violence thing every in the
fuck you doing.
So the sugar daddy showed up,
showed up at this comedy underground and was like coked up and drunk.
He looked like Anthony Bourdain,
the sugar that he fucked up.
I'm gonna fuck you up.
I just,
at the time I'm like,
I'm gonna beat this motherfucker.
Take his money.
You know what I mean?
I was in Seattle at the time.
I still so the cheap rat you out?
No,
they had witnesses.
no,
no.
How did,
how did this guy find out about you?
Is She ratted me out,
whatever.
I'm dating him and he was like,
I'm coming back to get you.
I'm fighting for your honor.
One of those things.
Yet we showed up.
Yeah.
And so he was just getting,
he was just getting some pussy for money.
They thought they were in love.
We pleased until this day.
He still calls her and sends her money.
She's 40 I'm 48 she's 43 stills tripping and Tampa.
Oh my gosh.
Still shaking the,
she was a millionaire and she's just bought her 10th curves gym.
Really can't.
She has a franchise fucking thing up and down Michigan.
She's still stripping stills tripping cause she's filthy fucking boy dick for a
hundred.
She'll fuck you for 200 at the Strip club.
Really?
Today.
She even told me when she goes,
I'm a little sick.
Does I sucked the guy's cock but no condom.
Oh my God.
Every time she sees me on TV or something,
boy.
So she called you and she just gives you the flow.
I just laughed my ass off.
This is like the craziest thing in my life and I play with sound sick con,
no condom.
I feel a little scratching my
cold.
Shy.
She goes,
yeah.
She goes to the PTA,
PTA,
the whole thing.
God takes him to Disneyland the whole fucking,
Oh my God.
Wasn't she dating some black karate guy or something like that?
That's the guy that tied her up and held a shot gun to her head.
This motherfucker shot,
this motherfucker found out she was sucking 10,000 decks and said,
I'm going out for it back and cigarettes.
He came back with a sick God,
a bottle of Tequila and a rope.
Oh No.
And he tied her up.
Man looked at the bench and he goes with his and tequilas gun,
um,
fucking shooting yet.
I'm slitting my wrists.
Whoa.
So he had her by Eddie's old school.
All right.
Ted Planet libray
down that block and right there if you make the left is the Chinese theater
right there.
So some cop was driving by and he sees him in the window.
This is a true story with a gun through the window is opened.
He's like,
I'm gonna kill you.
I love you.
He was pulling the same thing.
Well,
what's that movie?
Playboy 21 that they shot her with the fucking,
the best role is like fuck God.
Fuck the one with Mickey Rourke.
What was the one that the chick,
the playmate Roberts.
Eric Roberts.
That's his best fucking movie.
Yeah,
he puts a shotgun and a pussy and shit.
And then when she's dead he flux on the machine.
Or wait,
you never watched already tam?
I don't think so.
Oh my God was she was dead.
That's a true story.
After he killed million,
what's her name?
He built machines to weight lift,
but he also built machines to fuck women on.
So he made this bench and he cut the back of the bench down and he would,
so he could put your legs on your knees and he could fuck you from behind.
So it would just open.
Then he would strap your legs and not do as a sick cause.
That's what he was trying to do.
Well for her.
He was trying to sell the star ratings sex machine.
Whoa.
That's what the movie was about.
It's about Eric Robertson,
that chick.
He was fucking creepy in that.
And then I did some looking up into it.
That guy was fucking nuts over that bitch.
The real guy.
And the real story,
the real guy was Craig.
They wouldn't let them in the playboy mansion.
And then she was fucking somebody famous like a director.
You know,
this is the plot of the movie start rating.
No,
this is the real story in real life.
If you look it up,
wherever she was fucking,
she was fucking a famous director.
Who was it based on?
It was based on,
uh,
check it out.
Brian,
the girl from Canada that he was dry.
He was doing what?
Teacher contests and he signed the toll.
They got some pictures of it.
Got Her in playboy,
moved to La.
They were living the fucking dream,
you know,
and then he married,
he was a fucking mooch.
He married,
but he was trying to marry.
And every week you come to work,
I got to know why.
I did Joe Rogan,
I bought,
we do the Joe Rogan Test,
a pad,
you know,
every week he came to a new school and these are the scans he was doing.
Then when she divorced him,
she gave him money and said,
you could keep doing this dumb shit.
Then he invited her over something and that's when he fucking nice stuff.
Really?
But he banged her after she was dead and then he shot himself duck.
That's a sick motherfucker right there.
This is a lot of people that are like dat close to killing themselves on
Hollywood
clubs.
There's a lot.
Think of how many people lose it over women.
You know?
Really fucking lose it like that.
That's a,
yeah,
a lot.
Well,
You know,
it's,
you know what it's like.
It's like if you only have a dollar and someone takes your dollar,
it's got damn devastating.
But if you,
you know,
make $100 an hour and somebody takes your dollar,
you're like,
I can make another hundred dollars in an hour.
What's the big deal?
You know what I mean?
It's like when you have a,
for most guys,
the currency of Pussy is just overwhelmingly expensive.
It's overwhelming.
It's really hard,
really hard to get laid for the average cart for the average guy.
So you get a good one,
you get a hot piece of ass,
you get a hot bench that you're really attracted to and you love her and then
your emotions get tied up in her and then she wants a dump you and she wants to
leave you and that's your everything.
That's everything.
You got everything you got in the world.
The world is this chick.
That's the best thing you got going for you.
We've all met guys like that.
You ever met that one guy who's like not so good looking,
but he's got this hot bitch and she's just one of those girls that wants a guy
who's not going anywhere but just,
yeah,
she's one of those girls who wants to,
God that she knows that she can wrap her tapped out.
She said,
I'm not playing games with them.
More my age.
I don't want this shit no more.
Brian,
what are you doing over there buddy?
I was trying to look up that maybe,
what is it a story about who was the other girl?
Eric and who was the girl?
I haven't found it yet.
There's so many stories like that.
Right.
If a guy going nuts over a check,
hey in the sixth grade by,
that's why I got left back over New Yorker reasons,
pussy dog,
that pussy sent me for a loop with the sixth grade and sixth grade.
Cause you know when you were a kid you always see,
you always see pussy in playboy pictures and shit.
When you see that shit up close and personal.
That's the real deal though.
I couldn't even fly,
couldn't even think I had quit karate.
I just stopped talking to my friends,
just banging her just bag of dry humping.
It started drying up and I was sucking a little funnel teddies and then once I
got,
she told me she wouldn't give him.
She told me she wouldn't give me a piece of pussy till the day,
first day after school.
I couldn't wait till that last day of fucking sixth grade.
But my grades were so low,
like I always had great grades.
You just go in there and listen.
I don't even have to fucking study.
But all that was on my mind was banging this chick for three months.
Why?
My parents caught me with her in the closet at that house.
They was fucking horrible.
They don't make me go to the bar after with my own mom,
cock blocked me and they finally had to go to summer school.
If if you miss some school,
three days,
they leave your back.
I fucking even cut summer school.
Fuck it,
this pussy.
So by that time she was giving me the push.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I was just looking at it and looking at what the fuck was going on.
I was just doing little luck salad.
I was hoping it would meet me.
Do you remember when you first started actually having sex?
How often you would have sex?
Who was ridiculous?
And when you met a woman,
you didn't care about conversation.
When I was 18 I didn't even want you to talk to them.
I just wanted to fuck sucked.
And throw you the fuck out.
It was,
you got barely had anything in common.
No class mail communicate about any nothing,
nothing.
It was horrible.
What a horrible fucking way to live as a fucking man.
Horrible.
Yeah.
It's devastating,
right?
A fucking the weirdest places.
When I was young,
I fucked behind the Capitol School.
Oh my God.
I got in trouble all the time over dumb shit like that.
I don't know.
The one time I bang her frank behind Mike Mckinley school.
I was in the eighth grade.
She was a sophomore,
but I fucked the backwards.
I fucked her and then they ate her monkey.
I didn't know she was a virgin.
You fucked her and then you ate it.
I didn't know what I was doing,
dog.
I didn't know the fucking progress.
I,
I fucked that and they had a pussy,
but it was cold out so the blood flows out of my face.
You know what I'm saying?
I had done,
I went home,
my mother was like,
what are you the wolf man?
But then her fucking family hated specs.
They would chairman a fucking,
the aid,
its specs with a passion or brother wouldn't even talk to me in the court.
And One night I got her on her balcony cause after I fucked her,
she loves specs.
You don't understand me.
I was looking at that bloody monkey.
She fell in love with the Cuban and I had her outside when they finger banging
her heart and all of a sudden,
you know when you look,
I had to run the stairs.
I'm finger banging,
but I'm looking at people on the street.
Her father was right by watching you finger.
Fuck Joe Rogan coming out the hook and papers and she goes,
are you through yet?
Oh my God,
you walked off the balcony and I'd never seen her.
And she slapped her.
Are you fucking kidding home though?
She had three brothers that were fucking gorillas.
I'm surprised I'm still here.
God the father caught all by goddess.
You have no,
and then when I quite caught playing hooky with that girl that the sixth grade,
cause we used to go to school and then take off in the afternoons,
I go to shop.
Right.
I'd still like a bottle of blackberry brandy.
You know what I'm saying?
We'd drink a Q few swigs.
She'd let me suck a little teddies they called.
My mother was never home in the daytime,
but one day my mother's home,
they fucking call.
So me and this girl lived caddy house,
like there was a house behind mine next to her so I could just jump the fence
and on the corner of being in the house,
the windows were open and my mom's a fucking Spec fuck.
She's out there yelling and screaming
at the mother's next door and she's like,
Ooh.
That's what happens.
Ever since your daughter's been hanging out with my son,
they stay up in that sucker room and they fuck all afternoon.
Taught them how to Suck Dick,
who was killing my mother.
It was killing her.
It was killing us so much.
Even brought my uncle from California one day because they couldn't figure out
what I was doing in the room.
So he,
my uncle put,
they couldn't figure it out and all,
they were like,
what the fuck she doing?
Let's go see what he's doing.
So my stepfather and my mother and my uncle came to my house.
My uncle put a ladder in the back of the house.
He tried to climb up and shit.
Meanwhile,
I'm driving home.
I think I'm rocking her fucking world.
The ladder fell.
He's done that.
He goes meal,
I ain't Yo Smeal his legs fucking bro.
Don't take him to the house when I come I was going out but like we're fixing
pain.
Like I busted them write out like a week later my mother is like,
we're going to get you and get done my brother,
we're going to get you a little money to your brother because you did some ball.
My mother blamed on me cause they were going
to climb a ladder.
Fucking hysterical.
You understand me?
What I went through with this New Yorker or a razor girl.
Now she's on Facebook and she won't talk to me.
Here's the fucked up thing,
right?
Like two years after that
I messaged the twice I even fucking Farmville Farmville's I could sit and talk
to you,
but here's the deal.
What happened was when I was in the age when she was in the eighth grade,
I was just saying we weren't dating him,
but when we were friends,
we all played together on the street and I had this kid,
Valentine Pharaoh,
he was the mechanic on the block,
or I had this kid,
this kid was brilliant.
You brought them a stolen bicycle.
Within 10 minutes it was all duped up banana,
but you couldn't find that fucking serial number on that,
even if he wanted to.
But everyday when I come out,
he'd go cook or write this bike,
tell me if it needs any help.
They cook it right this.
But you know what I'm saying?
So I would get on the bike riding go bro,
the pedals,
you got to be more on the fucking pedals that don't maneuver.
Right.
So I wanted him to Charles Court and we were playing football and I put the
bicycle on the fucking floor.
So we're playing football,
basketball,
and she's on the block with her girlfriend.
She picks up the bicycle,
dog gets on and start driving the bicycle down the block.
Charles court was a loop,
a complete loop.
You know those streets that it's not a cult de sac.
And so you go in and have the island in the middle.
It was a loop.
So she went out in this way and we were going to catch her on this way.
So me and my buddies were going to capture over here and as we're gone for the
bikes,
you twist the handle bars and went over and fell.
She fell.
She got up.
She said she was okay.
She goes,
I'm fine.
We said,
you show it.
Yeah,
we were like giggling.
You know you'd,
somebody falls when you're the fucking seventh grade,
you giggle.
She went inside the next day,
went to school and they pulled me out and they go,
you hear what?
I'm [inaudible] girl.
He's got a blood clot.
I fucking brain.
Because when she hit the thing,
so I went to the hospital,
whatever.
What happened?
They were like,
Nah,
she got blood clot.
A couple of days later,
the brother hurt that,
you know,
something happened.
So he came to me and he goes,
Bro,
what happened that day?
I just want to know.
And it was me and my,
all my buddies were there,
my girlfriend,
we were all that.
She went away from the bicycle and went over into like weeds and shit.
But you must,
she wasn't bleeding or nothing,
bro.
She hit her hat.
She just hit that head.
So he always had like this.
Me and him never got along.
I mean he knew I was banging his fucking sister.
He heard all the stories.
So it was the weirdest Cuban house.
These motherfuckers are real specs.
The father and the mother had broken up,
but he was Cuban.
He ain't leaving nowhere.
You've got to take me out with bazookas.
This is my fucking house.
So he stayed in the house in the basement and built his own fucking apartment.
The basement won't even talk to them,
even a little hood.
So when he walked in and he'd have to look at their faces,
this is my house,
me out your [inaudible] sorry.
[inaudible] House.
I don't go no where my house and he wouldn't talk to her family.
We probably didn't talk to the family and talk to the girl who just talked to
the board for a vet,
you know the whole fucking did it cause it was bad to the bone.
So did the wife date,
new guys know the guy would go fucking crazy.
He'd stabbed motherfuckers,
the mother lived there,
the whole family was there.
A Nice House.
She was like a doctor Bro.
They had money.
These people might adult.
That's hilarious.
The funny thing was that I had gotten punished at that time and me and just get
out.
We were at war.
Like I kept hearing,
I'll be wanting to give you a hard time and shit.
So I told him,
my Stepdad one day I go,
dad,
this is what's going on in those people,
that girl.
And he goes,
fuck them.
Don't worry about it.
Right.
So one day me and my dad and that's the,
that's the first vision I got when I went in front of the house.
I had a shoot and I was explaining to people about the house.
And uh,
we had like a little garden in the front and the stairs.
And my dad would never hide guns in the house.
He would always hide them around.
Like if he came here to visit you,
he would come a day early and put a gun outside just in case something happened.
Like he was lonely.
Jack,
he's a bad mother for Swiss guy.
He used to hide all of guns and this and you know like a up the block and then
his fucking plants under the plants.
But he had a gun hidden.
No,
I never do this growing up.
I would mow that lawn.
That's how good of a idea he was.
He was brilliant.
He was just all night long and he had dones tucked away guns tucked under the
fucking law and I couldn't even see him.
So when they were out there with the fucking law and he's out there all specked
up with his white tee shirt and this big gold chain and white shorts and white
shoes and I'm,
I'm getting low and sweating and he wouldn't even do the long bag.
He would make me open the bag like this and he would pull the fucking shit in.
You know,
like,
like the tour met me,
so I see the white corvette pull up and it's,
I am,
I'll be in his father and I'm like that.
This is the fucking guy that was busting my balls about New Yorker.
You know,
he came out of my,
I never forget that.
My Dad just looked at him walking into the garden,
came out with the fucking 45 and he didn't even pointed out.
I mean there was people outside barbecue and people up there playing,
talking.
Nobody's seen the gun.
He just had an insight.
Anyway,
what's up?
They looked at him,
they walked three steps back with him.
He turned to them,
they got back in that corvette and I never seen that motherfucker.
Yeah,
I seen him in [inaudible] 93 at a Superbowl party.
How many different times have you seen people putting down his [inaudible]?
how many shoot?
Three.
Four,
three or four.
Wow.
It's a fucked up feeling when you see a gun pull up because even if it's not
pointed at you dog,
you think that's it?
That's the end of the park.
Anything can happen.
It's the end of the party because it's not the guy with the gun is people are
charging and how easy or trigger is half the time you said dog,
I hear gun unless the dude standing in front of it and got something to do with
me.
You never see these fat little legs move that fast.
You ever seen those videos online where dudes are Brolin and like a hip hop
party and then someone just yells gun to scatter and you hear,
you hear the gunshots and see the flash white towels everywhere.
I got nothing against shooting somebody.
If they're the person that it's unnecessary people that go down and that's what
kills me.
A kid playing on the street.
Well shoot somebody you have fucking house and shoot him if that's what you
would think.
Wait for nine one one do what you need to do.
I ain't mad at you.
It's the people that fucking like dog in life.
Sometimes people,
you know people lose that fucking man.
I know a kid one time that some guy in the street here,
Kipp New Orleans,
he went to his house,
got a gun,
and shot the mother and waited for the cops,
but they ain't going to do this.
People that feel that way about why if you don't in the south.
That's why I love the fucking south.
That's why I love it.
Did you see that thing with,
with Bj Penn and Matt Hughes?
He was shooting a 50 millimeter Smith and Wesson.
If I could have a 50 millimeter Smith and Wesson and my fucking car,
I'd walk around the south though.
He lives in Illinois.
That's the south as good as that.
That's of Fuck Chicago in Chicago,
Illinois.
This rule is,
fuck.
Yeah,
it's country.
It's country.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's country,
so it's still kind of the south that has that flavor.
Do you know what has a 50 caliber gun?
Cool.
Anthony from opie and Anthony.
He's got a 50 caliber fucking gun that he has to go to specific places to shoot
because you can't shoot it most places,
but the round,
it's like you're fucking fist man.
It's got damn cat crazy.
You don't need that,
but you do need it.
You don't need it,
but you do need,
it just goes down knowing that you can get one of those just shooing person with
that holy fuck.
I fucking right to bear arms.
It's just fucking people were ruined it.
I believe.
I believe in that.
Right.
I love Colorado,
but make my day law.
I'm sitting here talking to Brian,
hit my window one.
Can I see that light coming through the window?
Watch this.
Boom.
And I called nine one one.
What happened?
You're going to have a chance to put them.
Why would I?
It's a make my day law.
I'm inviting motherfuckers.
I'll put a person the window.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't get no,
I don't give a fuck.
[inaudible] make my day law.
Big Carrot.
Yeah.
You know you should have the right to protect you as write the fucking bear
arms.
You hear that?
What's going on with the ATF now that they're trying to pee?
People with medical marijuana licenses.
You're not allowed to buy new guns anymore.
That's why you quit,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
I get so many messages.
The fucking pro and con for that.
Again,
I got an argument.
They don't feel that I don't have an argument at all.
There's no argument there.
Just trying to slowly choke out medical marijuana and the only reason to try and
do it just because of the fucking pharmaceutical companies,
those comments,
you know this is,
this is a not a representative government anymore.
They represent pharmaceutical companies and giant corporations.
That's who they represent.
They don't represent the people anymore and people have inalienable rights and
one of them is the right to bear arms and a lot of people associate that with
right wing Wackos and this and that.
You know what?
That's a lot of it is because you never had your ass kicked.
Okay.
He never met crazy people.
You know,
you don't,
you don't respect the idea of hunting.
You know,
for whatever reason,
all of those,
all those readings are invalid.
Okay?
Because I know a lot of crazy motherfuckers and you would want to have a gun if
you knew some of the people that I knew and I've met,
you'd want to have a gun.
And if you knew some of the people that you met,
you'd want to have a fucking gun.
There's nothing wrong.
You can't fix the whole world all at once.
And until that he gotta be able to defend yourself.
Handguns,
well made,
fuck,
kill.
The ain't no good for nothing but data.
And if you like to drink whiskey,
you mad,
even shoot,
show,
sell,
good googly Moodley and again,
the guy says,
if you drink whiskey,
when was the last time you smoked a joint?
The said,
you know what?
I feel like shooting Brian.
Yeah,
that would only happen if you drank Tequila and shit like that.
A whisk and I cried argument.
They said that I'm wrong with that.
Who the fuck was it on this podcast?
I,
yeah,
I was talking about how Tequila makes me evil.
An angel different.
It will.
It's a stimulant.
The,
the,
you know,
that's really cute.
Well,
some people get up,
believe some people have this,
a feeling that alcohol is alcohol.
I think that there's different effects.
For me,
when I drink wine,
I have like a more relaxed sort of a feeling.
Wine relaxes me.
It might be horseshit.
It might be my head.
Um,
because it's not that strong of a difference.
When I drink Tequila or I drank Jack Daniels,
I get fired off.
I,
you see me when,
when we do jack shots before a show,
I'm like,
God damn,
I don't get like that.
When I drink a glass of wine.
I was drinking a glass of wine.
Don't,
I don't get to where I want to fucking just grab somebody and hug them and
squeeze them when I come at your mother Fucker,
you know,
but you have a shot of Jack.
You want to,
you want to squeeze people sometimes too hard.
I'm like Tequila for me,
I just,
I get evil and dark.
It forget,
like blackout very fast.
Really.
You black out and say creepy shit.
Tequila nights are the worst.
That's why I do.
What did you,
what?
Did you get some sort of a,
an argument recently?
Which a girl when you drop,
would you have that?
Uh,
no,
no.
Just natural.
Hey,
did you see these,
um,
uh,
to change the subject?
Did you see these photos of the,
uh,
the heads on Easter island.
They have bodies there.
Just look at this.
Check this out,
Joey.
You're just,
they're just digging these things out.
Yeah.
Look at this.
They always thought the were incredible because it's this deeper.
Nope,
no,
they're just trying to do it.
Now look at this.
Easter island is this crazy island that has these huge statues that they don't
know how the fuck they cut these things and how the fuck they move these things
into place because they're enormous and they must weigh an incredible amount
will now they found that they're way bigger than they thought and they go deep,
deep,
deep.
Are you sure this is not moot movie viral video photos is real shit dude.
Because don't you think the first thing they would do is like,
wait a second,
this goes deeper down.
You know,
why would they ever like there's somebody that has to trim the hedges and he's
probably like,
do you know it goes deeper like immediately?
Well,
you know,
I don't think they bothered,
I don't think they bothered digging in.
Sorry,
checking on me.
Cause the,
they look like,
you know,
they look pretty cool but they looked like that was the statue.
And I guess they just started digging deep below.
But they have petroglyphs.
It seems like there's a lot of markets.
Very dumb islander.
So look at this.
Look where this is really cool.
You see this photo?
Look at the hands,
see the thumbs,
two thumbs and the fingers and they have a petroglyphs on them where you could,
uh,
see some of the,
the stuff that's written on them.
It's not just one side either.
This detailing,
this is several sites,
some of them more and more detailed.
It's pretty interesting stuff.
This is another ancient civilization.
I don't know who the fuck belt these things.
They're going to be finding our shit someday.
Legit websites.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's on all sorts of Reps.
It's on a bunch of different websites.
This is a legit archeological discovery,
I'm pretty sure.
Well,
I mean it's a,
it's a private research company.
I don't know
Jody is,
I saw your podcast recently had an animated part on your podcast.
I thought it was brilliant.
I they took one like a small skit on,
on your podcasts and so many animated and it looks really good.
I was really happy with it.
Great fucking job with it.
Really fun polices the tiger,
right?
Like she,
she,
she set that up,
that all up.
She's an interesting lady.
She,
she's really good at that stuff.
She is specialty is and we need to get her on the pot.
Yeah,
she'll come on.
I called her today.
She didn't answer twice.
I called it twice but she was doing and she was cracking is probably getting,
I wonder,
does it come to Karaoke last?
She's coming this week.
This week?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It was called her up cause she wasn't,
she didn't have a babysitter last week.
She couldn't get the girl two nights in a row.
So she's definitely going with you.
She spoke about on the podcast.
Oh I told her.
Yeah,
she's a really neat girl man.
We'll have her on next time you come on and have Ron.
Come on.
She's a great fuck.
That'd be great man.
I'm really happy to have her in my life.
She makes me laugh cause she's so sweet to my fucking assholeishness.
Like when she tells me to her real views,
she's sweet but she's real,
just super honest about everything.
About sacks,
about,
she was talking about and she picked up this guy and his deck was like two red
bull cans because they save the guy.
See The guy,
you will die.
I believe that you should have seen the guy,
nerdy guy.
Right?
The nerdiest glasses.
Little hot on.
He was scared.
He didn't really want to say much and he goes,
oh well fuck.
It took me home.
He became an enemy.
He was trying to put fingers up my ass.
And then,
well she said she finish her mouth over his cock.
God Damn that she,
she goes,
Joey,
I got a big fucking mouth and he,
his cock was so,
I mean she just said it right out.
She just told her and she goes,
you got to sit down and I got to tell you something.
I know she's going to tell me about the podcast.
He said,
that guy was with the other day,
that guy had the biggest dick I ever saw in my life.
So good.
Fucking hilarious.
And she was telling me that they intimated that she enemy now.
And it's the story of fucking that guy.
That's her boyfriend.
That's hilarious.
So,
um,
this is Halloween and um,
this is appropriate story cause this shows you how out of touch these fucking
bankers are with people.
Have you seen this story where the top US foreclosure law firm through a
Halloween party or the staff dressed up as foreclosed upon Americans,
the staff dressed up on people who lost their home and saw the dress.
Look at these photos.
This was their fucking party will work for food.
He thinks it's hilarious.
He is a big fucking lawyers.
They put fake dirt on their face.
They pretend to be white.
It was the whole staff dressed up as this,
look at this shit.
Wow.
Third Party squatter.
I lost my home and I was never served.
Haha.
I think that's funny.
How fucking add a touch of day,
what kind of bad Karma,
unless you have just taken people's houses away,
kicking people's house and the houses left and right and left right,
left and right.
Crazy.
It always thinking about what you said.
We told him over the weekend about the pharmaceutical pharmaceutical prices.
I finally figured out why they're no fucking cause.
They got a kickback.
Oh yeah.
That's a big one for the doctors.
The politicians.
I mean,
you know.
Yeah.
You're paying a lot of people.
If you go to a doctor's office and he says,
do you have your three is,
hey,
you're not going to take that medication.
I'm on.
I got a better medication.
They start filling it out and she got to pay for research and development to,
wasn't a lot of money involved in creating pharmaceutical drugs too.
That's amazing.
How much more that paid for fucking pharmaceuticals.
That remains amazing.
And you're right.
That's cause they gotta kicked back,
kicked back like a motherfucker.
You know the doctor sells grates,
the most prescriptions of a thing gets like a cruise at the end of the fucking
year.
They take care of your dog.
Well they also take the whole staff out.
Mrs Rogan's mom's a nurse and they take her whole staff out.
They,
they,
they encourage you to use,
you know,
Welbutrin and whatever the fuck they're pushing.
And then they'll take the whole staff to like a nice dinner that they can't
afford a nice steak house and shit.
And you know,
it sits the whole system.
The whole situation is fucked.
It's completely ridiculous.
The fact,
and this is the number one reason why pot's illegal,
the number one reason,
there's a lot of money that they're throwing at all these goddamn politicians to
keep potter.
Lego can't stop it though at this point.
I don't believe he could stop it.
I believe at this point the well has been broken.
What are you hearing?
I don't think it will.
I think people get so angry.
You think about this,
occupy Wall Street shit and occupy La and occupied everywhere.
They're occupying fucking Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
Now they're occupying everywhere.
I could pay olive garden occupied,
don't have a card and he can't.
He can't.
He has to go every fucking podcast and say olive garden.
It's like he's a little joke.
He thinks he's cute anyway.
Um,
it's
when you,
you see how fucked up the world is and you,
you,
you find out that they're wasting the resources going after pot.
People are just going to get even more angry.
They have to be careful at this stage,
the way people are so angry and people are,
you know,
protesting so much and there's so much,
there's so much tension in the streets now.
There's so much,
so much of a,
an organized group of protesters now.
They have to be real careful about how much they try to take away because the
more they do it,
the more it becomes more and more crazy and more and more people join the cause.
This ain't going to get go anyway.
This,
this ain't going to be going away anytime soon.
The shits only going to get bigger.
Weird.
You know?
It's like you wonder what is,
what is exactly going to happen?
What is going to happen with the world because it's going in right now.
Things are going in the craziest direction that they've ever gone.
The the,
the biggest,
the most amount of change,
the most amount of fear,
the most amount of people that are upset and,
and the most technological discoveries,
the most amount of technological progress,
the most,
the craziest things like they have this new fucking laser that they're,
they're creating.
If you read about this world's most powerful.
This is the the headline,
powerful laser to tear apart the vacuum of space,
a laser powerful enough to tear apart the fabric of space could be built in
Britain as a major part of a major new scientific project that aims to answer
some of the most fundamental questions about the universe.
So some fucking crazy ass,
super powerful laser that,
what does that even mean?
It's going to tear apart the fabric fabric of space.
You know what the fuck does that mean?
Mild headaches?
I mean,
what are they doing?
What the,
what the fuck?
What is this?
I mean,
what's going to get there first?
Is it going to be people decide to blow up the earth because they're fucking mad
that the banker stole all the money or is it going to be some asshole pulls the
switch on this laser that you know that tears apart the fabric of the universe
and the whole universe becomes like a balloon with a hole in it and spins around
in a circle and fucking collapses in itself.
What is going on,
man?
Every day there's something new.
Every day there's something.
They were hustling,
hustling,
dude,
I my feed it and I give thanks to the fucking,
the day woke up.
I don't know what's going to happen.
You know,
it's getting scary out there.
It is.
Right.
It's fucking scary.
Guy That didn't know until I went to Houston.
I usually from the last time I went down and this time,
even when I went down there three years ago,
the oil was still booming and shit.
Oil is still booming.
Well,
whatever you would,
you notice that was a difference.
Couple empty fucking stores,
you know,
it was,
uh,
when I seen that I was,
when I go places that I went to in Houston now closed a couple of more than
usual,
more than usual.
And I think it's crazy as I,
that Brendan Walsh,
we did that podcast with them yesterday and the other two gay comics that he had
on,
they were talking and then like three out of four of us had been robbed by
gunpoint and we're like,
that's crazy.
In La [inaudible] la I Brendan.
Wow.
He got robbed in Cleveland,
right?
Yeah,
I mean in Ohio I know that that's the next move.
I know that burglaries are going to go of course what they have to unemployment.
That's the next fucking move.
Yeah,
they have to.
That's what happens.
You know,
people start robbing people because they're broke and they're fucking scared.
They need something.
Fuck.
That's amazing.
People getting robbed and stuff at gunpoint.
The damage.
That's it.
That's why you get out.
I have a fucking piece in your house at night because it's like anything,
a horse in a sword.
That's what I want.
A horse and a sword.
You unable to carry a sword.
If you wrote a horse,
he gets scared fucking fall off like I do.
I just jump off a fucking awesome.
So skin.
Yeah,
I got bucked off a horse last time by squeezing too hard.
I guess if you squeeze too hard when you're on there and you get scared.
I was scared cause I was a kid and I squeezed a hard bucked right off.
And then that same day my sister touched an electric fence and she was like
seven.
And he's like,
and I think we should stuck on the farms which are touching electric fence.
She was seven and she shot back.
Holy Fuck.
A bad day at the farm.
How does that not kill her?
Cause there's not that strong.
Yeah.
It's kind of like shock,
but nothing you've touched one Joey.
I touched something similar where they shock you with Shit fucking yeah,
it's definitely wakes you up.
Yeah.
That's scary as fuck dude.
An electric fence and s six.
How old was she?
It's like seven.
Fuck yeah.
You would think that would tell a kid electric fences and nuts studio of my own
way and
kill you.
Is it mostly for animals?
For the farms?
Yeah.
So like animals won't sneak in or sneak out real and they get kind of trained
to,
uh,
to avoid it.
To avoid it.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
I guess you want to keep your fucking animals.
Uh,
I love how some people,
like,
especially Texas,
this is real common.
They have what's called a high fence compound and they have all their animals
like wild animals on this compound and they just run around and shoot him all
year round.
Shoot whenever.
Like Ted Nugent has a spotlight that he has probably done in Michigan and now
he's got a spot like that in Texas.
I love it.
He lives on his fucking giant piece of property.
He's got like a thousand acres and he's got all these fucking animals running
around his property,
so he gets in his fucking four wheel drive.
It goes out to a spot,
waits in a tree,
sees a deer walk by,
shoots a hole in it.
It takes it home and eats it.
That's fucking beautiful.
Fuck a supermarket,
you know,
fucking supermarket.
When you got your own ecosystem in your backyard,
that's the shit,
dude.
If you could have a spot like that where you got your own lake in the backyard
and your own like hunting spot,
how cool would that be?
Would you not love that?
Why doesn't let me for me,
I can't kill a fucking animal.
Even if I wanted to.
You couldn't tell him that I'm,
but you love a good steak.
I listen,
listen.
I know the little world was covered.
Just don't tell me.
Listen,
you find you couldn't kill cows or you couldn't kill cats.
You couldn't kill dogs,
but you couldn't kill a cow.
I need that.
Did you hear about that guy that lived off?
My life to look at it as all on the floor.
Yeah,
every level at every.
It's unfortunate,
but that's how they have to die.
That's the only way.
I mean,
it's not even going to live forever if you don't do that,
but the ecosystem is the way I've seen.
I've been with people when they shot a deer,
just drag them.
You know what?
That's great,
man.
I got nothing against you.
I can't do it.
Can't do it.
I can't see it early.
I don't think I'd have any problem.
I tell people when I'm driving down the street and I see a bag on the road from
a mile away,
I crank up thinking that it's a puppy or something like that.
Yeah.
Then those are the stories that drive me the most fucking nuts.
When you hear about someone throwing a puppy out of a car,
fucking critical.
Well,
I just tickles me the fucked up.
You know what I mean?
Horses,
you know I don't,
I'm scared of horses.
I don't want to hear about you.
Shoot the fucking horse.
You know what?
I want to fucking see it.
The most disturbing thing ever to me was when I watched that Dang on 20 Hbo
sports when they were doing a dog fight and the guy goes,
you know what?
The dog's a piece of shit or whatever.
He got to put them on and they walked them into the weeds and you heard that he
walked by giggling.
Now I had to turn it off.
It was really a fucking puke man.
It's horrible.
You hear about that guy that lived off of road kill for 30 years and need from
the UK,
40 44 year old guy,
lived only off road kale for 30 years and he would cook like Badger,
sube,
raccoons stew,
like whatever he can find every day is what he ate offer ago.
Did you get an article on this guy?
Yeah,
it's on CNN.
Huffington post was roadkill.
His name is Jonathan Cohen.
Really
boiled it.
Yup.
Rats.
Fox's house pigeons.
Mold snakes.
Peasants.
Yep.
He eat roadkill for 30 years.
Oh my God.
And there's like a picture of him or video of him on CNN and you just the back
of his car.
He has like this little Saturn with this deer hanging out at the back of his car
that he found on the side of the road.
Well,
I know that a lot of people will find a dealer that got hit by a car and
they'll,
they'll shoot that or they're rather they're cooked that they'll take a deer
that got hit by a car.
No,
they'll gut it and take it home because you know that is as long as you know
when that thing got hit,
as long as you can go to it and it's not,
it has been sitting in the sun for a couple of,
it's not,
what's the deal with it when you go hug then Colorado cause this is why it got
everything.
All the knowledge I got behind him was in Colorado and people say that when you
come up on a deer,
if you shock them,
he releases that thing and the meats tougher.
Like I don't know what the breakdown was.
It again it would say dear God he died a weird death or something.
Like if we got a lung shot and he had a run and really quick,
oh he released the stars,
drove the meat gets it's adrenaline.
Adrenaline and I'm sorry.
And then if you shoot up with a bow and Arrow,
cause I have friends that were born out of a little bit dangerous people.
They would bow and Arrow guys.
Those are some or some of those are the most dangerous people I've met.
There was,
why is that?
Because they could shoot you with a bone.
I don't think it shows a piece.
They show up with a bone out first,
the pieces,
second
piece of seconds.
So that'll get your 30 yards.
They're going to get you at 50.
So does that supposedly make the meat tastes less good?
The bow and Arrow?
You know what,
I don't want my to get pissed at me.
I don't know the exact specific,
somebody from the south or somebody who knows what's going with Matt Hughes.
If you're fucking listen,
I guarantee you there's a bunch of people on Twitter that know about,
uh,
about hunting with,
with now,
you know,
I love poker.
I Love Boulder and you love boulder.
You love the people of Boulder.
Loved it.
I lived in boulder and 85 and I moved up to the hill.
I didn't even think I told you about these stories.
And I met these guys up on the hill that were Vietnam vets.
They sold weed or whatever.
And,
you know,
some of them were hippies and some of them are guys that look like,
Gosh,
you know,
straight up.
And I became friends and when the guy's name was that we would go to Vietnam,
you know,
we became friends.
I was lonely out there was 85 I was 21 and he got would go with him to the,
to the vet center and get his meds,
you know.
And then after awhile he introduced me to another event.
I would meet them.
And you know how you,
when I had a problem with my ex wife and her husband,
you know,
these are my friends just because they were crazy or whatever.
That guns where I respected them bro.
They went over there fucking 16 you know what I'm saying?
They were there 12 or 24 bodies.
They were telling me the stories and these guys were living in hell.
I knew it,
but I couldn't turn my back on them with my friends.
You know?
And it's funny,
you know,
you used to encourage me,
Joe,
you got to get healthy.
These guys were encouraging me to kill this mother fucker.
You understand me?
You know I don't like when you see somebody go Joey manual look like they were
like dog.
Did you think about when I told you you like I couldn't shake them.
That one guy,
the one,
not ads,
but his partner,
that guy specialized.
He used to show me after we meditate I take him up to the fucking uh,
uh,
the one canyon,
I'm sorry with the words sunshine,
one of those canyons.
And that's why I fucker one of those fucking canyon.
This motherfucker was hitting targets with a bow and arrow.
You would dream about even seeing well,
and he was telling me to do it whenever you want to kill his mother.
But he told me,
I go,
well how are you going to kill him?
I don't know about no bone arrow.
She's got,
you're going to have to kill him.
And I don't know.
I go,
I don't want to kill him and no gun.
He goes in boulder,
we don't need guns.
That's what I told you.
Cause we're taking them to the mountains.
We'll slice is fucking time we rub me that would make a syrup and peanut butter
and two days of bear.
Don't the only find the elbow cause the best,
only the elbow joint and be a tooth if he's sick of eating.
These guys were serious and every time I'd see him they're like dog,
did you think about that motherfucker right now?
He's fucking your ex wife right now.
He's hugging your door.
I mean they were like whoa.
And I love these guys.
Cause they were right.
They were like,
you know these guys would buy the book but there were Vietnam vets they stay
with.
You know,
so they didn't want you to kill him.
They wanted you to let them bleed out.
Oh these mother fuckers.
But that one guy,
Joe,
when you seen this guy with an Arrow,
your heart,
what's,
you're like this is a dangerous cause.
This was army train green baret army fucking hand to hand.
When he was a Rambo,
he was a modern day.
When they got hot,
that's who they let him in a helicopter.
He was missing two fingers,
you know,
the back of his calf.
Got Blown up,
you know the whole fucking deal.
But his face was throwing a lot of those guys back.
Now we're getting a lot of those guys now from Iraq and Afghanistan because I
been,
I've been meeting a lot of those guys after shows,
man.
A lot of guys that are limping on canes and Shit.
Dude,
the other day at the Ontario Improv,
show me this giant hole that was taken out of his leg.
Holy Fuck.
Blue bagged with you.
Imagine how lucky we are man.
And I'll tell you,
I was thinking about it this morning.
What?
He's a podcast fan by the way.
That dude,
whatever you name,
dog bad motherfucker.
That was one of my mistakes.
Not join the service.
Really.
One of your mistakes.
Look at you.
You turned out Joey Diaz,
she wouldn't have turned out Joey Diaz if you went and disciplined.
I would've been a 40 year old Joey Diaz on a nice pension.
I would have learned how to blow fucking people up.
I would've had a passport instead of not having a fucking passport.
I would have been just it bother you.
The passport thing.
Fuck.
Yeah,
I would've been in Japan right now.
You're going to England this weekend with a donkey up my ass haul routes and
routes to go stab somebody.
Like if I knew I had a blown head,
motherfuckers up like man on fire.
I go for the last bathhouse of the fucking year.
20 chicks look at my toes.
My ass also have seven Vietnamese kids who gives a fuck.
I'm born to kill somebody.
You understand that?
That dropped me out of a fucking helicopter.
You would want to do that.
What are you talking about?
You know why they said,
you know,
I didn't go to the service brokers.
I didn't want to take the blood test.
You didn't want to take,
I got the paperwork and everything.
How come you don't want to take the bullets?
Are you fucking kidding me?
At that age,
I wouldn't even allow you to fucking touch it with a needle.
Once.
I had no supervision.
I didn't go back to the doctor two,
I was fairly something dog.
Really?
Yeah.
I did all my own dental work.
I did every time I used to.
All your feet.
I care.
I ripped out with a fucking wrench with Jack Daniels or what?
I don't like needles dog.
You didn't know about that.
Why do you think I went back to acupuncture?
I want to eliminate,
I want to live.
Why do you think I started going to acupuncture?
Because I want to eliminate my fear of needles.
I was telling you that I'm going to have to go for a cortisone shot you had had
you had cavities cause you weren't brushing your teeth?
No I wouldn't.
I've never had it.
I always brushed my teeth.
So why didn't you ever been out?
Cause I wouldn't go to the dentist.
I just left the cavity go cause I wouldn't want to go to the dentist because of
my fear for me.
Ooh.
So you pulled it out with applier and I didn't get,
I didn't get a blood test at the time.
I was 14 she was baby sitting there with a pair of pliers.
Pull in your fucking time.
I was four.
I walked around for a year with an abscess.
The tooth was missing and I go up to people at him at the comedy store and it
would swell and like the press had that shoot out that people like,
Hey,
at the comedy store,
you know you can die from that shit for a year.
So that's why you can't drive without driver's license either.
They go in and sometimes it,
your brain isn't to me,
it got this big and then went up to that Cedar Sinai and the doctor just opened.
One of my friend went in his fucking face,
like the exorcist and never came back.
And then little by little I became friends with Dr Waxler.
A little by little he talked me into,
do you know how it was a process that goes into when I get a blood test,
what?
There's a process,
but it's ain't just Joey Diaz whipping up his arm.
What's the process?
It's fucking hard.
[inaudible]
he knows it's three days a horrible,
oh,
it fucking kills me.
It's his snake.
Here's Indiana Jones.
It's,
I don't like fucking needles.
I don't want to buy me.
And I went for a year.
The acupuncture,
I was faith every two times.
Really?
God,
yeah.
Especially when I'd see her put the truck and Neil and Mike Chester,
I dropped.
I hurt my knee because it doesn't do anything.
Nothing.
Look,
there's some people,
there was a girl I dated though her.
Her Dad was a dentist and her dad would faint when he saw anything bloody like
her.
His daughter came back from the beach there were at the beach and they got
Suntan Sunburn and they get sun burnt to the point where the kid had blisters.
She had blisters on her head.
Dad sees it,
falls down,
unconscious fucking falls down at the beach unconscious.
He was a dentist.
He couldn't see anyone get a needle and her and I were in the movies once and
she was watching him in the movie.
The guy shot himself up with heroin and she blacked out.
I faked that both fixture was,
she stuck with me.
I had to put a book that in my mouth.
I faked with Joe Daddy's.
Steven said,
well,
Gee,
Bj Penn,
my house at my house and woke up two hours later,
fucking,
oh,
it was hard.
Wife fainted at the Pearl at the palm and Ralphie May and somebody shot a bloody
towel stitch with the bully Tyler.
That's all I had to say.
Really?
I went down,
thank God there was a doctor next to me.
They picked me up a little bit.
The USA was embarrassed,
we will get you.
And they picked me up a little bit and they gave me water and that was fucking
fine.
What evolutionary reason would there be for you to black out when you see
something shocking that the best one was when I got locked up and went to
prison.
I'm like,
good,
I'm in a tube with 80 guys and they're like,
go,
you know you have to go get a blood test today.
And I'm like,
that's it.
I'm going to fucking get my blood.
This wake up with a Dick in my ass.
So I fucking thought about it.
I didn't talk to nobody,
but I just worked myself up the way I do before said I can't face your day as
you can't fake your Coco.
You're from North Bergen.
Get your shit together.
Did they let you lay down?
I had to go with one of those school chairs is stood up,
sat down with the school change.
I looked the other way.
Boom.
I willing to the tube.
All of these black dudes.
What up?
What up,
what up?
I didn't faith.
I was like,
fuck.
I evolved.
I got her man.
I put my arm down.
I picked up the cotton wall,
the little red.blue down like a bad fucking habit though.
I went through the dentist Terry three years ago to get a fucking root canal.
All of a sudden you're here.
Tell her he's like,
that's my husband.
He's going to come in with the oxygen and shit and they didn't see the needle.
I just tasted the blood and you blacked out.
Just the deal.
So why aren't you like like periods when goes down periods it just
listen to me.
When I was 16 I took,
we can carry it home or not.
I was best Keller cute girl.
She's sucking my Dick at a picnic and we were like 16 and I was in love.
I took her home one night.
I took her panties off,
she had a Kotex up and then went like this,
blah.
You know,
like when a,
when a tongue comes out,
when you go to a haunted house,
right.
When I pulled the the call to actions on it,
blah,
blah.
I seen this thing with that line of blood and I fainted.
She woke up,
she woke me up a little while later,
a little while,
like what happened?
She put,
that's the time they had the day.
When you go to the first aid kit,
you know those correlaries and things,
she put one of each nostril.
I had one
a first day.
Oh my.
Did she put one of these fucking nostrils?
I was telling these guys the story the other day when I was in Seattle,
one time of the stripper.
I was with her at the beach,
at this little lake and I was working her monkey with a wine cooler.
I'm working her money,
she's going for the hips of moving and I got that.
I'm working in with the month and I'm working that little monkey and I'm getting
all excited and when you see a bottle of the chick's pussy,
I don't care.
Even if you're a Catholic,
even if you're a Christian,
you're is going to get hard and that's a complete different animal and I'm just
working the clit with the bottle.
The suction got ahold of the Pussy and awesome.
The period came out of it like a string and I just felt like like a cutter.
So I dropped,
I dropped Jack.
Let me tell you something.
That's two times I fucked a women.
That was the one time and that girl when I was 16 never again.
When a woman says that's her area,
I don't even look that your store is closed.
Don't worry about it.
Only so no periods,
no,
I don't even have a gun.
The older I get,
the more,
I don't know.
I used to be the same way now.
No,
no,
no.
That's disgusting.
I don't want to pick a glides out from my time.
You picked up a chicken Boston.
One time I started at Google 93 I think of back to the wholesale.
Started nailing.
I fucking turn the lights on.
There was blood everywhere.
I went down and she was a soldier.
She was home.
I leave this bitch with stem like myth.
Let's go into combat zone and he was asleep.
I black the black,
the fuck I always black and he's the one who has think like if I could be next
to you,
you can fight somebody and you could bleed a little bit and I could see gross
shit.
It's as soon as I see a little bit of blood on my shirt,
it's that thing with Bj Penn,
Daddy Stevenson.
That was part of the other day.
I had to turn the TV off and Nate Marquardt hit uh,
channel center with an upward elbow.
At one point you could see the blood drop Chels somethings.
I can't see that.
That's the shit that kills me.
Like that night.
I took the asset to UFC.
I'm wait,
please,
Lord,
don't let nobody get beat up bad tonight.
[inaudible] out of here by ambulance.
I took it.
I remember like,
oh no,
it's crazy.
You could put your finger in a girl's ass hole.
Pull out aluminum foil,
stick you dig back in there.
No problem.
But there's any period blood.
If I would've pulled it a little bit farther,
Ras,
a little bloke came out,
I would've dropped right there.
They don't have no fucking wake me up in the aluminum,
but also explains why he always gets his steaks.
Well done.
Yeah.
You get your steak.
Well done.
Nothing like that.
Well,
I just don't like the taste of blood on my dish when I was a kid that's broke.
My mom made a dish.
More wealth,
more or less done than you added.
Cuba's call it with though with,
what's that?
What that means?
S s done with that word.
What does the word mean?
Turn.
Turn with that means spending time.
That's it went that way.
So just brace it on the wayside.
Yeah.
Two minutes done.
Pink.
Red,
disgusting.
Wow.
Like what they call bow and they call it now and you're probably like $80 for it
and that's a sheep.
Oh yeah.
Todd Todd,
Todd,
Todd.
That shit,
by the way,
don't go to a bad place to get it.
That's easily the one of the most weight.
The easiest way to get a few points.
That ain't shit.
Oh Shit.
I got it the other day for me to her tire from any tartare.
How do you know you got it from that though?
Immediately me and my girlfriend got sick and like two hours a fucking,
I forget the name of firefly from Ohio.
You're not supposed to be drunk.
I don't.
Let me tell you again.
I never heard about it.
I didn't even know what it was before I've had,
it doesn't taste that good steak tastes good when the outside is cooked,
you know that's what it tastes good.
I like medium rare.
That's to me is perfect.
That's around and you see and you slice into it and that's how a stakes was be
cooked.
You get plenty of rare meat in the middle,
but the outside cook is what gives it that fucking delicious flavor steak
tartare is like very mild.
There's like not that much flavor to it,
like really rare steak,
like a piece of Philemon Yawn.
If you cut out the outside of it and just had the red park,
it's not that flavorful.
You know the real flavor comes from the outside being cooked and all the fat
melting and all that shit.
You know?
That's where the real flavor of the meat comes in.
Can you imagine Joe Rogan music?
You a sci fi that beat you up,
you get cut and he's black.
Oh,
if he cuts and I'm on the bottom that he bleeds out.
Just a little bit of drugs.
Now I know if I get it,
if I would kill ideas,
I'm just going to pick my nose really hard to start to bleed.
You know what I'm saying?
Punch yourself in the nose.
How fucking weird is that?
It's those little,
and I should correct myself,
it's those drops.
When you watch the Gipsy,
which ditch has a town,
they throw it to the side.
Oh,
you know what you should do?
Punch yourself in the nose and then blow your nose on them.
It'd be like amazing.
I would just faith,
I would just puke probably.
I have no problem with blood and I'd sent,
well obviously I don't,
otherwise I couldn't be doing what I do and I have no problem with period blood.
That's never bothered though.
Would you eat mostly with
I don't give a fuck.
I had a gentleman swallows.
You're calm.
And then once the kitchen,
I don't give a fuck.
She swelled up closer.
Say it doesn't matter.
Even if it's been my body.
What's my Dick is hard.
I'm crazy man.
Let's go back at time.
So I got to ask you guys questions.
Okay,
so girl wants a,
Miami told me until they could quit.
When I pulled it off,
I seen the little fuse and I put the pants,
tampon.
She goes,
no,
go,
go.
It's really different.
She goes,
it's the third day,
the third day,
and I'm like,
I don't even know what she was talking about going.
She doesn't mean,
I don't know,
like damn if for a period so that the third day means it's,
it's probably not as thick,
but it's more of an oil base period.
A fucking
fake.
Just listen to that.
Oh good.
Greg dressing.
It's like that black blood that comes on.
You know what?
Sometimes it's really dark when you go to wood ranch to the back.
French salad.
Oh,
it's from the staff in the back of the corner that's now just falling off the
walls of the vagina or weird situation.
You know the whole thing just bleeds every 28 days.
What the hell doesn't die?
What a shitty.
Whoa.
We've got to back this up guys.
Okay,
so the third day you take the underwear off and they've got a cigar sticking my
lip.
Boosie you fit pussy with this fuse is sticking up.
Let's get back to this.
You pull it out on the side.
Brian,
I'll fucking strangle you.
Right.
Killing me with that shit.
Just tell me the truth.
I need this knowledge and don't to take it out.
I lick her pussy or either clip.
But do you leave the cigar it?
No,
no,
no.
You want it.
I'll pull it out.
I'll take it in and don't give a never working with cigar.
A little play with it.
I don't use it as my,
that I get sick.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Oh you pop it out it out.
It's usually,
you know,
honestly,
it's usually not that bad.
Like it's like if you fuck her then it starts to come out on your Dick a little.
But it's not like you take it out and it just,
blood starts going everywhere.
It's more like,
it's just deep in there.
Have you ever tasted monkey?
Yeah.
It just tastes like a joints.
Yeah,
sure.
Oh cause I coins to go suck on the corridor.
That's,
it tastes very copper.
Like,
yeah,
it's not that bad.
But what's the difference in blood and Pussy?
Pussy liquid,
you know,
it's all liquids.
You Saliva,
you're swapping spit,
you shoot loads of nerve and blood.
That's the nucleus and the nucleus.
The nucleus of the new head.
That's the whole patois liquid of life.
It doesn't matter.
But what does it feel like?
This girl was telling me that when you fucker on it period.
It's tremendous.
Yeah,
they love it.
Feels good.
Does it feel good for us?
Well that's why you see here it's warmer too.
It's more of like a warm juice.
You get sloppy.
Yeah.
Sometimes you get sloppy sometimes blood everywhere.
Like Goddamn fucking crabs here.
Yeah.
See my mom would keep the sheets every year for Halloween that she accidentally
spotted on and that would be the ghost outfit.
So like I always looked like a ghost.
I got shot.
Look good Joe Terry Lowe
again.
Motherfucker wrote that you can tell when he works materials,
his lips quiver and he's like please get this out.
I just want to make sure I get this out.
Good.
Just have a tear that's actually true and its material
and would always be like the ghost.
It was like yellow on one side.
Right on the other side.
At least in you've told me that.
But these guys,
yes you would have said Japanese flag able to fucking close up Madam.
Cause everybody the Japanese flag.
What's a white flag with a red.in the middle?
People saying,
welcome to my bathroom.
My wife was in there and look like a Japanese flag.
I've never heard that.
Steve McGrew does it.
Oh,
it's a bit,
it's a,
it's a joke.
Okay,
then I've heard other people do it,
isn't he?
I'm one of those guys that went to England,
became an English comedian.
Is he one of those?
Steve.
Steve One.
I'm like funny guy though.
Denver guy originally does.
Yeah.
A lot of guys do that though,
right?
You go to England.
Always mister boasting.
Macgruber he's very funny.
He writes a lot.
He's the real deal.
I always missed the boat.
Huh?
In what way?
He moved to Houston.
This of stuff was going to la,
just to Denver as blue collar comedy was blown up,
so he's always been,
I thought he was always the original guy.
I haven't been one student.
When I first got into economy,
Steve was the king of Denver.
Hands down.
Roseann had left and Steve was the next big thing.
Then was you had to go see him.
They would go see him,
they would go watch him,
you know,
uh,
all the Roseanne's people that have been Roseanne became a big comic out of
that.
But there were two other people that followed that became huge writers.
Now Holly,
yes.
Big Deals at Disney.
Created a bunch of shows.
A lot of them didn't stick around.
I forget what their names are,
but uh,
that was a great scene back then.
And then all the underlings were great writers because that was what the guy
with the hooks is from Denver.
Yeah.
What that was his name,
one hook,
one hook.
Goddammit aren't members.
And he's a great writer.
George from Denver,
great writer.
You know,
it was just so Rickards.
Great.
These guys were great fucking writers,
man.
You know.
Well,
Denver was a great scene.
It's still a great scene.
There's not that many scenes,
man.
There's not that many comedy scenes.
And this is,
Austin has a scene.
San Francisco as a scene.
Denver as a nice scene.
Boston,
I guess,
still has a little bit of a scene,
but not really.
Yeah.
Holding on took deal.
I feel so bad because it was the right place.
One of the best
time when I was there in the 1980s EITs to this day,
state is one of the best comedy club communities in the history of standup
comedy.
It,
the 19,
late 1980s in Boston.
It was a monster scene.
It was monsters.
Here's the deal that the comics should take over.
That city been tried,
just set up tarred.
It's hard that,
you know,
they,
they need a leader,
you know,
they need that.
They need a,
a whole new movement down there,
I guess.
You know,
there,
there's some guys putting it together,
you know,
I know.
Um,
I think they got some new club in Faneuil hall.
Didn't he hear about that?
I know rich Vos was playing out it.
Tim Macintyre's club,
I believe.
Uh,
it's,
there's still talented guys there.
There's a few guys.
But man,
it's just not what it used to be.
Anything about Patrice O'Neal?
Anybody?
I haven't heard anything.
I just heard it's bad.
It's bad stroke.
It's,
I don't,
I don't know any details.
And what about Ralphie may is rounding out there.
Here the hospital is fully,
I heard my prayers go out to him and his family.
I just heard that a,
he's an ICU in Tampa.
His wife was dead.
Was Nicola [inaudible] pneumonia,
the Boleo the ship on his Twitter,
the pneumonia for a long time.
Like every time I looked at it as Twitter is like,
he still has pneumonia.
What the fuck?
He was in the,
he was in the infirmary on the ship,
so he will have shipped to do comedy with this guy that's a big radio.
He's like the how it started at Tampa has that area,
what's the guy's name?
I forgot.
Bullhead Kao Callahan.
Cow Head count.
Heads radio.
They do a cruise like your c got sick on the group's.
Wow Man.
Cow,
cow,
cow.
There's a lot of Chicago man,
man,
cow uh,
is not on Chicago anymore,
I don't think.
I think he was on the Internet and he had some sort of internet thing going on.
Now I don't know what's going on with that guy.
I used to follow him on Twitter,
but I haven't seen any of his shit in a while.
So they said that,
uh,
he had a blood clot in his leg this morning.
That's it.
The last thing they told me about how dangerous is it be?
Like I said,
I got it from three horses,
so I got it from messages.
So once I get it from her,
say what's wrong or what's wrong?
Well,
you look at a guy like Patrice and you know,
he's obviously physically really big and definitely overweight and not healthy.
But Ralph,
he's bigger than him.
You know,
it's Robert bigger than him then.
Oh yeah.
Ralphie's Patrice never got as big as Ralphy Patrice,
a big fucking guy.
He put Patrice was locked Paula.
Yeah.
But Theresa is a lot taller.
Thanks.
From Boston originally.
Yup.
Him and Bill Burr,
the last wave.
There's the last wave of talented guys to leave Boston.
I mean,
I'm not saying this guys couldn't come out of there and right now still and may
get,
but Patrice and bill bird,
we're the last guys that I was hearing them out.
They were like a little bit after me,
you know,
I've tried,
I left,
let's,
you know,
we're all gonna go jelly.
So the two matter of prolonging this experience and staying as healthy as
possible while you're enjoying this experience,
but the way Patrice has gone,
we're all going to go eventually.
You ready to go?
Not yet.
No,
I have ready yet.
I,
I have work to do.
I have a lot of shit to do here.
I'm still not done and I have kids and I like them.
I like hanging around with them.
That's the only like I though you or you've always been pretty open about your
opinions about space and satellites and all the other stuff.
And it's weird,
like as I was growing up,
I didn't have time to think of a lot of things.
You know,
I had my mind focused on how to fucking rock and roll every day have to survive.
But there's one thing that's always intrigued me and that's the day before,
you know,
what do you feel that the week before?
Like when you know you're going to die?
Yeah.
Like you just feel that,
uh,
yeah.
I just want to know that.
You know,
you're always talking about time machines.
My,
my actually all this technology.
Yeah.
I wish I had a time machine for one day.
You always heard that people said,
I wish I had 10 years back.
I wish I had it for one day just to be a kid again.
Just to have that feeling,
to run around,
to see those people.
I come right back and probably fucking mice myself as well.
And that's the only,
but I always wanted it.
What happens when you close your eyes?
Like what the fuck do you go?
So that always intrigues the fuck out of me.
Right.
While,
while,
while I was with Steve Jobs said before,
those were his last words.
Oh Wow.
It's when the DMT kicked in.
Oh,
it's
crazy because it's so weird how the DMT works.
You ever hear stories?
Like I heard a friend of mine,
Oh,
his mom was dying.
She goes,
open the curtains and let me go join my grandfather.
You know?
And people always say,
well,
you had a spiritual experience done.
That's a BMT.
You dumb motherfucker.
You've known about these people all your fucking life.
You know,
they're out there.
So now that's a DMT taken yet what we know your brain makes the craziest shit
that you could take.
That's,
that's pretty weird.
That your own human body great.
Makes the strongest psychedelic drug known to man and your own body makes it
like,
what purpose is that?
What,
why does,
why would your body make that?
Well,
it's crazy because I'm a little doorway though.
Somebody was telling me,
I think it's rabbits.
The rabbits have something naturally that before they get attacked by a hawk or
an animal crackers,
that body goes into some thing that puts him in like a euphoric state really?
So they know they're going to go if they have it.
I feel that all animals and even us,
we have to have it in a way.
It's probably part of life.
It's probably,
you know,
one day we'll probably find out that what life is,
is just,
uh,
a brief experience and an infinite number of experiences that this one type of d
reality.
There's one dimension,
life,
human life as we exist in right now on this planet,
in this solar system.
It's really just a part of an infinite number of different experiences and then
this is just one of them and the next one might be something completely outside
of your body.
It might be some,
some crazy dimension of infinite geometric patterns,
and then the next one,
it might be something different.
It might be a constant cycle.
We don't know.
Did you ever feel something like,
did you think about something and feel something that was strong about you?
Did you ever think you were here before?
It's possible.
It's possible that you live your life over and over and over again,
just as possible as it is to live your life.
It's just as possible that you might live the exact same life over and over
again.
Who knows?
We literally might live it over and over again until we get it right.
You think you were like,
I always think of the back of my mind,
seriously,
three guys in the fucking room and telling you what I thought I was before this.
I think it was a room and fucking soldier real.
Just something about that time that's always fucking made me weak whenever
either one of them going to church.
Why?
I like religion,
you know?
It's something,
it's a door.
I like when I lived in Boulder,
I went to the rope institute.
I enjoyed all those readings.
I enjoyed the Buddhist religion.
It's very interesting.
The thing that's always killed me as the 12 stations in to crush that thing or a
church always just killed me.
I don't know what that is.
It's,
it's the,
the last steps of Jesus,
how he got fucking beat up and he started,
Mary Magdalen wiped his face and they hit him with a stick.
And you know,
that's always really,
I don't know why.
That's all that feeling has always made me feel like I could say I was a cowboy
and a previous,
so you really feel like at one point in time you lived in the Roman empire,
the Roman Empire.
I don't know.
Like whenever I hear that I worked with Caligula,
I don't like it.
It means [inaudible] whatever the fuck it meant,
that movie,
whatever.
But it's like I heard it before when I heard it didn't the,
well,
you know,
there's a lot of people that believe that memories passed down through genetics
and that's why you're afraid of certain things as a kid.
Like you know,
like a little kids are always scared of monsters.
And the reason there isn't a long time ago,
you know,
when we were monkeys,
you were,
people were getting eat and left and right by Jaguar.
So what are you scared of?
You're scared of something in a night that has big teeth.
Why?
Cause it's cats,
you know?
And some people would get away from those big cats and survive and then they
would retain those memories and those memories literally would be transferred
from their DNA into the next generation.
You're on fire today.
It makes sense,
right?
I saved and goes,
I talked to somebody who said,
I know why this is.
I always thought I was a Roman soldier,
but this was what sealed it.
Somebody said to me that that thing you have with blood as a mechanism,
I looked it up,
a mechanism mechanism my body used because my ancestors were warriors and that
was a mechanism they use when people came and slayed them,
they would make believe that from the blood they would pass out.
It was a bachelor of soldiers thought they were dead.
I fucking sweat.
Get the name of it.
I will look that up.
Hilarious.
So many people around you were killed by sword.
When you see blood blood,
the lockout lock,
the fucking held.
A few people would survive.
They would survive.
What a fucked up thing for somebody to say to me.
I was like wow,
wow.
And I went home going,
holy fuck,
I definitely got a smoke weed by two o'clock cause that was big for this shit.
Cause I tell people I always want,
no,
you want to overcome your fears.
We all do.
You know I hated heights.
I became a fucking roof or in college,
I don't give a fuck.
Give me,
you know,
the only way to on purpose,
the only way to fucking be scared of heights is to look at,
I don't even look at a lot of what do I got to bring up the saliva,
put that motherfucker on your thing or walk up with one hand and the thing
wasn't walking up.
It was getting back on the ladder off that room.
That's the confidence.
I did that for 18 months just to fucking,
I'm one of those guys on a ladder from a roof to a lot of these very off left
and right and
windows
broken windows in fucking big skyscrapers and they have those,
those fucking guys slowly work their way down the skyscraper.
Carrie must not be molested by ground.
Steve Burke,
one of my good friends was a window Washer at the World Trade Center.
Oh my buddy was like a Kansan dining was the guy who was a supervisor.
He ran the crews that and they had 16 my hands are sweating.
You're talking about that.
My hands just started sweating or thinking about being a windshield Washer,
the washer and the day he was an outlet in the day they got hit.
He was at the bar across the street banging it.
Oh my God.
It was a,
yeah,
it was a Monday or Tuesday.
He couldn't,
the first time they got back there was,
it was a Friday.
He was across the street bank and drinks too and I'm all nervous.
The second time he got banged,
they got the tower was hit.
He was still down in the Jersey shore.
That was just vacation week,
two times.
That's incredible.
He was,
he don't say much.
I mean Steve was always the wheel and he's the one that stopped drinking.
He was the one that drank every day in the 80s when the Iran captains,
the 144 days,
he didn't take a shower,
drink real.
We would play football with the mud from the summer.
It was fucking hard,
but that was his,
he was crazy.
He was always crazy,
but so we did it out of solidarity for at one point of his life.
Do they have like windshield washers.
They had them all the way up to like the hundredth and all your job is windows.
You know by the time you get to this one you got to do that one.
So you just go up.
So it's every day.
That's a day because there's so many.
And then you know,
sometimes
I need to change the scenery.
What?
70 88th street.
He know.
Does anything you go to AVH streets,
they probably got like a,
you know,
44 buildings.
You probably don't even get paid that well.
Oh Fuck No.
Yeah,
you do your union dirty and $40 an hour benefit.
Why don't they just think dirty five hour weeks,
you know any bad,
I mean for working fucking stiff with balls and neighborhood,
it's not a bad fucking job.
You know,
he would have just like self washing windows,
copies of water hose.
Now you would think they would have a,
yeah,
you were there.
It would be open a little bit so you can replace the blade,
put it back on.
I don't exactly know,
but I bet the union probably of avoids that.
They probably have a contrast with the construction unions to make sure that
they have the window washers union in the city.
All right.
Does the end of this podcast motherfucking treating her as a pirate?
I'm happy Halloween to all you bitches file Joey Diaz on Twitter.
It's mad flavor,
mad flavor on Twitter.
And he also has a podcast on iTunes beauty and the beast with the aforementioned
Felicia Michael's of course,
red van is red ban on Twitter and fire Joe Rogan on Twitter.
Thank you to the pod.
To what?
To The podcasting Federation of America,
the number one we're now number one.
I love to say thank you.
The flashlight.
That's right.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
And uh,
like I said,
the only one that hasn't used as Joey,
he uh,
he refuses.
But that's cool.
Don't forget at OCC 48,
54 Lankershim,
they've got these $5 cookies.
I'm fucked up right there.
And overhead divided the wellness,
whatever.
And those cc go.
They're telling me,
you see me and they give you a free fucking cookie.
That's what it really,
yeah.
You say you saw Joe is you get a free cookie.
Where are they out again?
Four,
eight,
five,
four language.
Am I going get a lot of people going in there for you?
I'm going to start meeting people like Thursdays from four to six that it's,
what is it again for waiting for a five for Lancashire.
My lower eight five four lab.
He had a great people surge.
The girl Vianna the fuck.
What's the name of it again and Ohsu?
Well,
you know I'm fucked up.
What's with the questions?
I feel like I'm alone.
People can go that OCC.
Say Joe Dsn.
Yeah.
Get yourself a free try.
Bitches.
Thank you to onnit.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancement supplements.
I take them every day.
Our blue ones,
we've got a 90 stack now.
Oh Shit.
Look at the Alpha brain and a,
yeah,
that's the alien because that fucking whole holy stuff.
That's the alien hodjat field especially.
They have a bunch of Zombie.
They have robot flashlights now.
It looks like you're fucking a Cyborg.
Yeah,
it's all that.
They're very creative.
Those slash they offered Lindsay Lohan a million bucks to take a mold of her
pussy now that I wouldn't have,
would understand why she wouldn't do that.
The best idea ever.
She's just do it.
Probably will keep her at a Disney movies for life.
That's not what the fuck.
A rubber to go that deep and that fucking dead snatch.
That's like sticking a fucking pipe in Bremerton.
Colorado.
Rub It.
The Washington deepest point.
Can you imagine how good I bet you got good nasty Irish cycles on it.
Make it orange with freckles.
Freckles,
so smells like fucking wine and cigarettes.
Marlboro light time.
He's just smell a little shuffle.
You think of the fucking Marlboro man.
Have you ever scratched your balls and anyway,
it's too bad and you had to wake up,
go up and like wash him.
I did.
This podcast is over Brian.
It's just Brian [inaudible] with the time when were rubber rocks every
Wednesdays ass.
You're killing me.
Can I have?
Everybody was saying tomorrow [inaudible] supposed to be on tomorrow,
but I haven't been in contact with them.
Hopefully we'll deal with him.
Shane Smith is unfortunately in New York,
so we're still trying to work that out.
We'll figure out how to do it.
We might try Skype.
Can we do a Skype when Brian said possible,
it sounds like shit.
All right.
Well,
we'll make it happen.
Bitching Halloween.
Happy Halloween.
Thank you all.
Keep it together.
Stay black.
[inaudible] [inaudible].